you
welcome everyone.
It's Thursday, May 14th, 2026 530 p.m. and we are met in the chambers of the city of Huntsville and this meeting of the Huntsville City Council will be called to order.
We welcome everyone who has joined us here in chambers with us as well as those who are joining us on our many streaming platforms.
We will begin our meeting as is our practice with an invocation offered by one of our Huntsville, Alabama police safety chaplains, chaplain Willie Hinton, who will be followed by Pledge of Allegiance given by Council Member Michelle Watkins.
All those who wish to stand and are able to do so, please stand for the invocation and pledge.
Chaplain.
Our Father in our God, we come now thank you for the city council.
We pray that that would be given the wisdom to lead and to guide to work together and be concerned about the citizens of this city.
We thank you for all that they are doing and all that they're planning on doing.
Let them acknowledge you so that you can direct their pain. Bless us all in Jesus name.
We pray. Amen.
Thank you, Chaplain Hinton.
Thank you, Miss Watkins.
Council members, you have the agenda before you.
Please note that item 18 C has been deleted at the request of the sponsor.
Is anyone aware of any other changes?
Yes, Madam President, sponsor of item seven a I'd like to withdraw it from the agenda for tonight.
Thank you, Mr. Meredith.
I noted.
Are there any other changes?
Is there a motion to approve the agenda with deletion of the agenda?
With deletion of item seven a and 18 C motion for Mr.
Kling second for Mr.
Little. All in favor, please indicate.
Opposed. Motion carries.
Council members, you also have the minutes of the regular meeting of the city council held on April 23rd, 2026.
Are there any changes or additions to those?
Yes, Madam President.
I've been meaning to say this for a while now, but the the time that the meeting is over should be reflected in the in the minutes and they haven't been.
Thank you very much for that.
No, we will not.
Any other changes or additions?
Then those minutes will be approved as they have been presented.
We have no special recognitions from the mayor, but we do have a point of order.
Can we add what time it was actually ended?
As opposed to the way they were submitted because the way they were submitted doesn't have the time.
Okay, this this Edwards.
Could you help us with that?
Shondra, Edward City Clark, we can amend the minutes.
The question I think is what time the way you stated is they will be accepted as presented and I want to make that with with the addition of that.
Thank you.
The time that it was that we can do that.
Thank you. Thank you.
We have no special presentations from the mayor.
We will move on to several recognitions from Councilmember six.
A is a resolution honoring the legacy leadership and community impact of all as our court number one eighty one of Huntsville, Alabama is their motion to approve motion from second from Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate any opposed.
The motion carries this Watkins.
Would you like to make that presentation?
Good evening.
Can I get the fabulous ladies in white?
Don't they look lovely to come up on the stage, please?
So I can recognize you with the resolution.
While they're coming up, I'm going to talk about community service.
One of the reasons I recognize a lot of organizations is the community service and everything that they give back in the community.
A lot of times we see people in the community and sometimes you come over on this side as well.
We don't give them their their respect, their recognition.
We don't give them the opportunity to be recognized.
And so a lot of times when you see me bring people here, it's because I want them to get the recognition for working in the community.
So whereas the city council and mayor of Huntsville, Alabama has is honored to recognize Al Alzar Court one eight one and auxiliary of the Imperial Court
orders for its longstanding commitment to service, leadership and community empowerment.
Whereas Al Alzar Court one eight one was organized in nineteen seventy nine and officially chartered on August 18th, 1980 under the visionary leadership of daughter Dorothy Lyons.
Whereas since its founding, the court has demonstrated a legacy of excellence by electing twenty four daughters to serve as illustrious commanders, each contributing to the organization's growth, impact and commitment to service.
Whereas Al Alzar Court one eight one is currently led by illustrious commanders M.
Carlin Jones, the twenty fourth commander alongside deputy of the Oasis, daughter Linda Satterfield said sorry PC and advisory past potent noble Barrington Dames is Barrington here.
Whose leadership continues to uphold and advance the court's mission and legacy. Whereas a nonprofit, they are dedicated to the betterment and well-being of the community through meaningful outreach service initiatives and charitable contributions.
Whereas the court's mission is carried out through impactful programs focused on community service, education, daughters of Imperial Court, mentoring excellence, which is called dying first aid and health awareness and voter registration among other initiatives.
Designed to uplift and empower individuals and families. They continue to serve as a catalyst for positive change both locally and beyond building stronger communities while leaving a legacy of service that extends beyond a lifetime.
Whereas the organization's own believer in dedication to service leadership and community engagement brings pride and recognition to the city of Huntsville and serves as an inspiration to others throughout the mid throughout the region.
Can we give them a round of applause?
And I'm going to ask Miss Colleen.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you to the city of Huntsville.
We are an auxiliary of women and we consist of 69 ladies and we just serve the community.
And if you want to check us out, check us out on Facebook.
And it tells you what we do throughout throughout the year.
We do have balls and everything coming up.
We would like to have your presence there, but we do want to accept this resolution and we do.
We just want to say thank you and thank you.
Thank you ladies for the good work you do in the community.
It is appreciated and noted.
Six B is a resolution recognizing the month of May 2026 as ALS awareness awareness month.
The chair moves for approval.
Is there a second second from Mr. Little?
All in favor.
Aye. Any opposed?
Motion carries.
Would Stuart Overman, Marsha Oberman, Lauren Duaro and is Miss Sherry Koche Shack here?
If you all would come forward please for the presentation.
It is my honor to present this resolution today.
Whereas the city council and mayor of the city of Huntsville, Alabama,
wish to recognize the month of May 2026 as ALS awareness month,
acknowledging the thousands of Americans who are affected by the fatal disease
and advocating for increased awareness research and funding.
And whereas amyotrophic lateral sclerosis, you can see why they call it ALS,
also commonly known as Lou Gehrig's disease is a progressive fatal neurodegenerative disease.
And whereas thousands of ALS cases are reported each year.
Whereas on average patients diagnosed with ALS survive only two to five years from the time of diagnosis.
And even though the exact cause of ALS is unknown, there is no cure for ALS.
It has been clinically proven that individuals who have served in the military are more likely
to develop ALS and succumb to the disease.
Whereas due to this uncertain causes and undeveloped cures, securing access to new therapies,
durable medical equipment and communication technologies is of vital importance to people living with ALS.
Additionally, clinical trials play a pivotal role in treatments enhancing quality of life
and fostering assistive technologies.
Whereas supporting such efforts, the ALS Association is the largest philanthropic funder of ALS research globally
and has committed more than $154 million to support more than 550 projects across the United States
and 18 countries demonstrating an unwavering commitment to make ALS livable and curable for everyone everywhere.
Whereas Amy atrophic lateral sclerosis awareness month provides an opportunity to increase public awareness
of the dire circumstances of people living with ALS.
Now therefore be it resolved that the city council and mayor of the city of Huntsville, Alabama
do hereby recognize the month of May 2026 as ALS awareness month.
May this resolution serve as a call to action to all Americans to join supporting ALS research,
advocating for increased funding and standing in solidarity with those affected by this relentless disease.
Mr. Obermann, would you like to make some comments?
Thank you, Council President Robinson and Mayor Battle and City Council.
On behalf of my family who lost our son from ALS back in 2010 who was 28 years old at the time
and Sherry Koschak is here representing the ALS Association's clinic.
We have a certified center of excellence here in Huntsville.
It was the first one in the state and we serve typically about 25 patients in Huntsville and Madison County
at all times about 250 throughout the state of Alabama.
As Jenny said, it's a fatal disease.
There's no cure.
People my age refer to it as Lou Gehrig's disease.
That's easier to say than myotrophic lateral sclerosis.
But this awareness is very important for people to understand the grave circumstances
with which families deal after a diagnosis and helps us raise money,
helps us get people involved to support those families because it's really not a disease that one person deals with.
It's a family and a community that comes together.
And this resolution will be important for helping raise awareness
and we really appreciate your stepping up and helping us recognize that for the month of May.
I present that resolution to you then and thank you all for the good work you have done in honor of your son, memory of your son.
I've had several friends who have succumbed to ALS and one who is valiantly fighting right now.
So thank you for that look.
Thank you.
And then finally, sixth seat.
Is a resolution honoring the memory and legacy of Dave Gallagher, lovingly known by the community as Microwave Dave.
Second.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second from Mr. Kling.
All in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed?
The motion carries.
Mr. Kling and Mr. Little, would you like to make that presentation?
Well, I believe based upon what we have been told by members of the family and the foundation
that they wanted us to wait and do the presentations of the resolution as well as we have two other things later in the agenda,
19A and 19B, and all of this is supposed to be officially presented at a very special graduation ceremony.
That's going to be going on at the Von Braun Center this coming Sunday from four to eight.
And so I'm going to just basically hold back until then, but we've got a beautiful street sign four feet long that we're going to be presenting at that time.
All right. Well, I see members of the foundation here. They are nodding their heads.
So we will hold presentation of that resolution until the special graduation ceremony.
That concludes then our resolutions for adoption and presentation.
We will move on to announcements and presentations.
Item 7A has been withdrawn at the request of the sponsor.
Item 7B is presentations to the Council on International Education Exchange, CIEE, high school students, sponsored by the United States Department of State, Cindy James and Jim Powers, local coordinator leaders.
This does not require action, but we will simply make the presentation at this time.
So, Mr. Powers, Ms. James, would you like to come forward and bring your students with you?
Just line up right here.
Mr. Powers, if you would please share with us a little bit about the exchange program, how it works and the benefits to our community.
Cindy and I have been doing international exchange for many, many years, and we feel like it is a very good thing bringing the world closer together.
I personally have hosted 19 times, so I have sons and daughters all over the world, and it is a very rewarding thing.
Today we have a number of students.
Some of them are with the Council on International Education Exchange, CIEE, and then we have one student who is with the Pan-Atlantic Foundation.
There are other organizations that bring international exchange students to the country, but these are the two that are represented here today.
You have spent many years doing this work, and we thank you for it.
These students have been here all year attending various schools.
As I call your name, I am going to present you with a certificate, and if you would please tell us which school you were associated with this year.
First is Sina Fursten-Mansara from Germany.
I am in Hartzell, and I go to the Hartzell High School.
All right, we are going to try this.
Thunyatron Suwannaprasith, he told me just to call him Pon, is that right, Pan? He is from Thailand, where apparently they really like vowels.
I go to Lee High School.
Thunyatron Suwannaprasith.
Nataniel Weichmann from Germany.
I go to the James Clements High School here in Madison.
Paravarahara Nitayavard.
Hi, my name is Paravarahara Nitayavard, but you can call me Pan.
I live in Falkville, but I go to Hartzell High School.
Hartzell High School, very good.
Emil Meyer, Germany.
Yeah, I live in Decatur, but I also go to the Hartzell High School.
Adrian Ebo from France.
I am a proud patriot from Bob Jones High School, circuit, James Clements.
Lea Schulz, Germany.
Oh, Lea had to leave. And what school was she at? Hartzell, very good.
Well, we are grateful for the work that you all do. We hope you'll present this to Lea.
Thank you and safe travels home.
Oh, yeah, yeah, sorry. I was thinking about the rest of the meeting.
I did note that Mr. Little took everybody, the students on a tour of City Hall before the meeting began. So thank you, Mr. Little, for helping with that.
All right. Now we will go on with the rest of the meeting. We have no matters with outside legal representative. We have public hearings to be held.
Nine a is a public hearing on the proposed creation of a tax increment financing district tentatively named nine pursuant Alabama Code Section 11 dash nine nine dash one established and set on this was set up the April 23rd, twenty twenty six regular council meeting.
This is a little different council members from most of the public hearings we have. It is required by state statute. We have Mr. Davis here with us. He This is the first step in creating a district.
He will make the presentation for us. We will open the hearing, have comments from anyone in the public who would want to ask comments or questions.
And then as opposed to our normal order of business, we will have council members who can make comments, ask questions. We will then close the hearing.
And then in the future course, we will have several agenda items that will come forward for us to take action on. But no action will be taken today.
So we will begin with Mr. Davis's presentation. Thank you, Madam President. Good evening council members and public chain.
Davis director, urban economic development. So council members wise before you, I want to go back to the previous council meeting most recent.
You set this public hearing that we're conducting now tonight. You also passed one other resolution for the Alabama Constitution directing the administration to present a project plan for this proposed district nine TIF district.
And that's what the administration is presenting both to you and to the public tonight.
So since 2000, as you're well aware, the city of Huntsville has established two financing districts as permitted under the Alabama Constitution to finance public infrastructure investments, the creation of district is a tool allows municipalities to promote economic development redevelopment
due to public investments made within a TIF district. The principles very simple city makes public improvements to entice the read development of areas or the new development areas to increase the tax base that would not otherwise be seen without these type of improvements
being made in a nutshell. It says that this district without the inducement of these public improvements would stay relatively flat from a tax based perspective.
We've been very successful. This would be tip number nine.
Miss Smith finance director regularly gives you quarterly updates of those TIF districts, most of those have been closed out they've closed out early and brought new significant tax base, both to us Madison County and our school systems.
People commonly misunderstand what a TIF district means.
There are times when you hear tax district you think your taxes are being increased. That is not the case. So what happens in a TIF district is the taxes that are being produced in that district, as of today continues to go to the tax recipients,
that being state of Alabama, Madison County, city of Huntsville, and our education system partners that tax base will continue to flow to all tax recipients, those who are paying taxes, citizens, businesses on property taxes their millage rate stays unchanged.
Their assessment remains unchanged. So it is not a tax increase. What the TIF district does is capture any new taxes within that boundary that will be created in those new tax base as a result of these public improvements has induced redevelopment or new
developed within the district. Those new taxes that are created are temporarily diverted to pay off the public improvements once the public improvements been paid off all that new tax base gets divided up and goes to the tax recipients.
So, we've seen that multi million dollars of new tax base when we pay these off that goes to our school system Madison County and certainly to the general fund of the city of Huntsville.
So, if this proposed district nine that we are bringing before you as requested in that resolution last council meeting would primarily consists of central portions of the city the downtown and, and, and a little north and south of what we refer to as a central
business district where we stand tonight.
It would encompass about 3089 acres which is pretty typical of our last two tests to six and test seven that acreage is very similar to that, and is similar to previous tip dishes are now closed.
All the proposed activities and public works projects within the project plan would take place within the corporate limits of the city of Huntsville that work cannot take place outside our corporate limits per state law, the proposed to nine district contain
the district under the tip statute that are, we believe, currently, undeveloped or underutilized its highest in best use hasn't been seen yet.
And that will continue to do will stimulate that redevelopment and more private investment area, which will elevate the tax base for all tax recipients. Furthermore, you know the redevelopment of these local areas and project will not be fully realized.
So there's no private investment without the project plan and these projects we're going to show you the proposed project plan we have brought you tonight would allow up to $220 million of qualifying public investments within the district would consist of five
projects, and by state law, all five projects must be started within a five year period, if they're not, what would happen is that project would not move forward. And that qualifying $220 million would be reduced by that project amount.
So this is a geographical boundary of what we're bringing to use the proposed district. You can see the northern boundary is just a little north of Oakwood Avenue, the southern boundary around Drake Avenue, the east boundary at California.
And then the western boundary being a 565 14th Street, kind of that that stovehouse district if you will that is had some investment we believe there's a lot more investment to be made or can be made in that general area, includes the low mill area, and that
central business district district of the city.
The project plan, the proposed district plan would capture, as I mentioned before, property tax millage under the state constitution of all new development or redevelopment properties within that district boundary I just showed you the increment tax tax capture
13 meals of the city of Huntsville millage 27 and a half meals, it goes to education and 11 meals from Madison County that's the same of all previous eight tip district we've ever done. Okay, that that is designated by state law.
In the case of the TIF nine district, we would start the full implementation of the proposed public improvements. And it's anticipated, based on our modeling that upon completion we could see 15 to $17 million of a new tax base created within the district.
And I don't say that's not the private investment that is the net new property taxes within the district that these projects would create naturally that 15 to $17 million gets distributed across the tax recipients being the city of Huntsville or education system
in Madison County.
So, one of the five projects expansion the bomb run center North Hall expansion estimated cost is $200 million North Huntsville Beltline Greenway project at $5 million.
A new Mill Creek Park will be part of our choice neighborhood initiative in partnership with us HUD and Huntsville Housing Authority at $5 million.
Low Avenue improvements to support the new hospital middle school. That's $5 million of public improvements that would ordinarily would be born by that school project.
Adam Street, Low Avenue, the redevelopment the repositioning that school there's a lot of pedestrian to make sure we've got public safety for for that school as it opens renovations of the former for federal courthouse in conversations with Madison County Commission
to see what the future of the existing courthouse site looks like.
What they do know is they will need a temporary location regardless of what that project.
Final scope of work looks like.
So, in partnership with that is to make renovations the federal courthouse GSA provided to the city such that it meets ADA and operable standards for the general public to conduct business in that at the end of the day those improvements are asset to the city of Huntsville
by state law with this project plan. All project costs shall not exceed the total of $220 million certainly can be less, and that will be our goal is these are estimates they're conservative estimates we will.
Should you vote on this, not tonight, but as we get into probably next month.
Our goal will be to do this most effectively and efficiently from a call standpoint.
And this starts to show in a little more detail. These five projects naturally they got to be designed.
So you know we, we don't have engineering drawings and schematics we you know, we would get into that upon the adoption of the district so the Vaughan Braun Center North Hall expansion of the general scope of work would be construction of a new North Hall exhibit area, upgrade
new service areas new meeting rooms conferences exhibit space upgraded parking and new South Hall entrances access bridge to all part of Huntsville drives to accommodate people coming and going with the expansion of the North Hall, and then other
things that are needed to complete the project, or that's utility modifications, and the like. The North Huntsville Beltline Greenway as you can see that project would start in the central business district downtown so it would connect to our ongoing park project
and carry north to Oakwood. That project will continue actually the Alabama and him over multiple phases. And we believe that project will do a lot is what it did for the city of Atlanta Beltline, so we know that North Parkway has been challenged due to its
broadening of being able to bring commercial development there. We believe this project will allow that front is not so much the front the parkway but front Washington Street Meridian Street in this Beltline Greenway such that we can see a various mixed
development on the east side of the parkway as we get into North Huntsville. So that would be the design and construction acquisition right away, or easement acquisitions, public green space lighting landscape and hardscape safety equipment, and the
like that would go with a project that that projects not just the Greenway. If you know anything about the land of Beltline, it has pocket parts has places for people to gather. So that's what that project was started that first phase of what we're calling
North Huntsville Beltline Greenway. Three would be the new Mill Creek Park, which is the redevelopment in partnership with us HUD and the housing authority to bring new housing to the residents of Mill Creek but also various price points of mixed income
housing that master plan has a public park. What is now right now drainage ditch to enclose that and to do a really first class part in in around not just for that neighborhood but for a downtown low mill improvements as I mentioned this is in support of the new
school Huntsville City Schools is working on for Huntsville Middle. That's to improve a portion of low Avenue from its current configuration to accommodate increased vehicle traffic and turning movements but also improve pedestrian facilities for safety
and any necessary public drainage improvements to help support the school system with that project. And then lastly renovations to the former federal courthouse that we were that was donated to the city, regardless of its long term use Madison County Commission
believes they can use it temporarily but we were charged by the government services agency to uphold and take care of that facility. So this is a way to do that and put that to use. So what do we think the results and where those results would occur from a private
investment area standpoint within this district. The shaded circles that you see are properties that we have identified that are prime for either their vacant and we believe these projects will stimulate private activities and interest in those and areas that we know that would be induced due to these amenities to see some redevelopment.
As you can see north to south is predominantly west of the historic district residential areas of our downtown but goes as far north as far south excuse me as Bob Wallace and Drake Avenue area. A lot of redevelopment activity in low mill and certainly in and around the Vaughan-Bruns Center.
And then as we get north of Holmes Avenue in that area you actually see along Holmes Avenue. We believe new development will occur just outside the district which is, which is great. That would be immediate new tax base to all recipients, the district would not capture any of that new development
outside this boundary. So that would be an immediate new revenue stream. So what are next steps as I said tonight, you will take no action. We are bringing you the plan as you asked for the last council meeting.
So, after this meeting, or the next by state laws we will provide notice to designated representatives for future meetings to be conducted by the local governing body that governing body is the city of Huntsville toward deferred tax recipients there's two of those
that's Huntsville City Schools so that represented that we would contact with Dr. Clarence Sutton the superintendent of schools, and then the Madison County Commission which will be Chairman Rex Bond. Those meetings would then get set and scheduled between those two
tax recipients. You see I've got to be determined but those would happen rather quickly. And then, somewhere in the May 25 week timeline, Huntsville City Council President by state law presents a male copy of this project plan to those recipients in its final form.
And what that would be is if there's any changes to amount of funding you want to put on these projects or new projects that we want to add to increase the limit.
Our modeling shows that we are comfortable at this amount, such that we can get these projects completed and start working at this TIF closed out and move on and that the new tax base go back to the tax recipients.
May 28 meeting if we stay on track you adoption by resolution by this city council certifying the plan meaning this plan is final. That doesn't mean you've approved the tip it just means there's no changes this this would be the plan to be voted on.
When you certified that the first group that would vote and approve this district is actually the Madison County Commission. And then after their approval, this body would take this up for a vote currently scheduled for June 11.
Upon your approval of the district. The last remaining on was our finance director will make application of this TIF district to the mass county tax assessor, which would define and identify all parcels within the district that would be in in the new tax increment financing district.
After that, on June 15, the district would be active and ready for any tax increment obligations to carry out these five project plans.
I answer any questions the general public may have, Madam President or this body.
The public hearing on the proposed creation of a tax increment financing district tentatively named TIF nine is now open.
So, again, we will offer the public an opportunity first and then council members. So the is there anyone from the public who wishes to comment on this item.
Good evening, Joy Johnson. I am the resident of Huntsville.
I am in general opposed to the idea of a TIF because it bakes in the necessity of growth, which is, of course, the logic of a cancer cell.
I hear a lot here about private investments. Private investors are not going to invest in what we need.
Affordable housing. Where's our affordable housing manager? Why isn't she here? What I want to know what she thinks of this plan.
Also, what's up with Mill Creek? This has been on the table for a long time. How come it hasn't happened?
All of those people that lost their public housing and supposed to be getting it back and it just never happens and never happens.
And now it's waiting on this process to maybe it'll happen one day. I don't get it.
And if you build affordable housing, it's not what this private.
It's not what you're planning on these private investors to do because you won't get those big tax dollars out of that. But that's nonetheless what we need desperately.
And will private investors be putting green energy on their investments? Is there any thought to resilience and sustainability and those kind of things going into these plans?
Does Planning Commission care about that? What's up? Thank you.
Thank you, Miss Johnson. Is there anyone else from the public who wishes to comment on this item?
Anyone else wishing to comment? Yes, sir.
My name is Darren Vraag of Huntsville.
I understand the reason for the TIF. My only question is why is there so much investment just going into the Vaughan Braun Center instead of what the previous resident was saying?
Affordable housing or also within the TIF district is the public transportation hub there as well. There's no investment going there and any other services, it seems like. 90 percent of it is just going into the Vaughan Braun Center.
Thank you for that input. Are there any other comments from the public regarding the creation of the TIF-9 district?
All right, council members, then this would be your opportunity. Council members, do you have comments or questions for Mr. Davis? Mr. Little.
I just got one. Low mill, as we know, is in the county. Will it stay in the county even though it's part of the TIF? Is there any plans for that to ever be?
Because obviously there'd be growth around it, as we're already seeing. Does it just stay like it is?
So it's a good question. So if you look on the screen, you actually see a black box within the larger district. That is actually low mill, so that is carved out of the district because it has to be in corporate limits.
So to answer your question, so we make these improvements and we start to see stimulated redevelopment and development. Hypothetically, let's say low mill annexes into the city and there's, you know, a hundred million dollar investment that happens on the low mill campus.
Those new tax base as a result would stay outside the district because once the district is created, it is set. So to answer your question, two years into this, three years into this, low mill size become part of the city, big mixed use development comes in there.
Those new taxes created out of that project would go immediately to the tax recipients. They would not go into the district.
Okay, good. Thank you.
Any other questions for Mr little.
Other questions Mr clean.
I want to go back and this is probably repetitive I just want to make sure it's spelled out for the public.
John Doe has a house right in the middle of this district.
And he pays x dollars. I don't know let's say pays $500 a year property tax.
This thing goes into effect.
How much is his property tax going to rise as a result of this tip.
So it's a good question so, or is it.
So here's what I will tell you, I can't guarantee anything the city of Huntsville is not placing any new tax on anyone.
So if we call our general public we have to vote on any new millage tax rate to be placed on that group we're currently 58 miles Mass County tax assessor does determines the assessment of any property and assesses and collects those taxes.
As of today, if you approve this in June and come October your tax bill was $100. There's a very very highly likelihood it's $100.
So typically, through inflation or something they say okay there's a 3% value in all of our homes whether you're in a tax district or not.
The tax assessor assumes that responsibility and does that assessment, but the way your taxes calculated will not change.
So let's say your house, the taxes and your house worth 2% more than it was last year.
So you pay an additional $5.80 per hundred on that additional 2%. So, for me to say no your taxes will not go up, I know what you're getting to the question.
And I would answer that is yes it would not go up due to this tax district, but if the tax assessor, due to just the rising cost of value of homes or your business said, you know, your, your business building is now worth but you know, because inflation 2% increase, whether in a district or not the tax assessor determines that but we are not placing any new tax on anybody in the district.
Just to correct me, so this, this tip, it basically works on, can we call it new areas or underdeveloped areas and those improvements are what are going to pay for the tips so that would be separate from, you know, somebody who's already there.
Yes, that's correct. So, your example of, you know, Shane Davis pays a is in this district they pay a hundred, I pay $100 a year in property taxes.
My $100 I paid mass counting tax assessor every year that $100 gets divided amongst the tax recipients city of Huntsville Mass County the school system state, and it continues to flow to them as if nothing ever happened.
Okay, is there a timer How are you going to address. We had some questions that were asked by the public you're going to bring it up later.
Yes, sir. I wanted to answer all questions by the council members and then I've made notes and I will address those this is a public hearing I do want to provide comment to that.
Okay, thank you. Thank you.
Mr. Merritt.
Is the sky bridge in the pin hook Creek mediation projects within the tip. Yes, sir it is. How is, are they going to be affected or what is the additional effect of those projects now that will when it becomes a part of this tip tip, if it is in fact passed by the council
good question Council Mayor so those projects are federally funded through two different federal grant projects the tip district will have no bearing on diverting those funds to a different project, or the tip district paying any portion of those projects so that project is,
is a standalone for federal grant actually to federal grant projects it's funded and under construction.
Thank you so in effect there's going to be no impact of this tip on the construction of the scribe bridge and the mediation. Correct. Yes, sir. Thank you.
So, five million of this is for renovation to the former courthouse, ostensibly, so that it can be used by the county commission is the county commission going to reimburse the city for these $5 million, or are we going to recapture that money based on leasing
the building to the commission.
So, to be determined, what it is our facility, the taxpayers of Huntsville owns the facility. One of the reasons the federal courts built a new federal courthouse is it was in extensive need of renovations of, you know, it's kind of the gift that keeps on giving, you know, that they
required to give it to someone they don't want to multiple buildings and being serious say limits. So, regardless if it's at long term use, a city department goes in there or museum, whatever. There's renovations that need to be made. We want to make those renovations.
The county commission has asked, would it be a possible temporary location for them. We've said yes, naturally, that would be a determination by this body. So at least would have to be structured between the city of Huntsville and the Mass County Commission brought before this
body and you vote on it. So, to answer your question, not directly there, are they going to pass $5 million back to those renovations because it's not an asset they will long term only because it's actually our asset, but there would be some type of revenue stream, should they, they go into it.
And that would be a separate vote, at least, as you mentioned, that would come before this body at a later date.
I guess my concern is these renovations, they're going to have a, we'll call it heavier hand in it since they're going to be the initial tenant so you were going to make these reservations, not reservation renovations to accommodate them.
So, to me there's, they've got some skin in this game of spending our money so how do we recoup that I hear what you're saying about, no matter who goes in there, ADA is going to have to happen and those sorts of things but there are going to be things that the commission wants
specific to the commission that when they get their new place and they leave is going to really have no value or potentially have no value to the next person.
Any better green point, I'm not, I don't think we're contemplating spending $5 million to tailor make the former Federal courthouse to fit their use.
So it would be general upgrades, HVAC equipment, ADA bathrooms, which it does not have, ADA access, just general upgrades.
Should the county want to use that temporarily, I could see them in that lease saying, we need to put an additional X amount of money in this for it to be properly the way we want to use it.
And we have to get into a lot of details, it may be upon your exit of this, we want these items removed.
You know, so that's, that's down the road but these general improvements is just to get the building to where we as the owner and GSA is requiring us to keep it to some minimum standard to get to that standard, such that whether the county uses it temporarily or we have a permanent use for it, that the general public can adequately come in and out of that building that we own.
Thank you very much, Mr. Davis, Madam President.
Ms. Watkins, do you have any comments?
If I might, in response to Mr. Meredith to.
We've got to realize that this is a partnership that we're doing here, we're using city money we're using county money because portion of that property taxes that goes up would be county money.
We're using schools money so it is a partnership with all of us working together to make sure that this is something that benefits the whole community so it's a partnership with all three different entities there.
So if I might ask, Mr. Klein.
I think I can kind of echo something along along the line.
That seems to be the exception, not the rules compared to what I see and hear from other areas around the country. I remember way back when I was a victim of the 1989 tornado in Airport Road. There were a lot of county vehicles a lot of county people who came to help the city of Huntsville when it was going through this type of disaster.
We help the county when they have issues. And I think it's a good thing. We work with the school system we have a good teamwork approach we go out for economic development projects we lobby up in Washington DC it's city, county, and again that's a teamwork approach.
And they have been good I've kind of kept my eyes open but they have been pretty good about helping us on things. I know we get a lot of site preparation a lot of road work that they do on some of our projects, and again, I'm sure there's some evaluation that's done, but I do like the cooperation
we have. It's a good teamwork approach and I think this would just be a component of that.
I can't add Mayor Bowdard does bring up a good point in these deferred tax recipients. I believe all but two previous tax districts that have been created had some form of capital investment to our school system.
The very first tip was really small, you know we we wanted to go try this and it was University Drive West West of Research Park Boulevard and it helped bring West Side Center with a target center is we made a small little improvement for the state of Alabama for
$172 an intersection, and that thing was paid off a blink of an eye was almost a test for us so that did not have an education piece. The only other one that I can recall that did not actually did was TIFF six and that was the players, and we contemplated
building a new school out there as things progressed we realized working with the school system, the location of where we proposed that wasn't the right spot long term. Even though it was in the plan we did not build it. But those are the only two out of nine.
Councilman Meredith knows we're working on possibly another TIFF district in limestone County would have a significant value to our school system out there to help them with with growth and infrastructure so we try to look and make sure we realize that
that new deferral of new taxes not deferral of any existing tax base but that new deferral is try to go help our tax recipients with something that they have upcoming or need, then you get in this district so everyone tries to get some wind out of the district,
while it's active.
I was just clarifying that that was actually going to be one of my first questions because it always comes up with the tips, is it going to negatively impact revenue to the school system in the short term. And the answer is no, that they will continue to receive the same tax revenues that they are receiving now.
And in the long term, as we have seen pay off recently with the most Toyota tip, they will see an increase in revenue so it will benefit the school system. You noted on your timeline when the Madison County Commission would approve the TIFF plan, is the Board of Education required to also approve the TIFF plan?
So by state law there are only two governing bodies that have to adopt any TIFF district, one that is the county governing body whether it's in Madison County or Limestone County and this body.
But they have been informed. Yeah, we were required to inform all tax recipients, but the only two tax recipients that have to vote on the district is a Madison County Commission in this case, and the Huntsville City Council.
We're going to have a joint meeting with the school system on June 1st and if it is appropriate at that time perhaps if there are any questions from any board members about TIFF 9, that might be an appropriate time to maybe have a discussion about it.
Absolutely. And we'll also be down the road a little bit on our plan, on formalizing our plan as well. A question has been asked regarding the VBC expansion, that's a really good question.
Why is the VBC expansion so important and why are we investing so much money in that? What is the community benefit?
If I can zoom out a little more than the VBC and then I'll answer specifically to the Vaughan-Bron Center expansion.
So within the TIFF statute of Alabama law, one thing we have to do is define a district and within that district there are certain qualifying parameters to qualify for a TIFF district.
So there's always a balance between how large to make the district to do as many projects as you want to do, but also keep in mind the organic growth that just is generally happening in our community due to new jobs and population growth.
We do not want to over capture that new growth and further defer new tax base to our tax recipients. So there's this balance of how big do you make it or how small do you make it such that you get what you think is the top priorities that are occurring within that area of the district,
whether that's in Limestone County, the need for utilities and infrastructure due to the growth or new education facilities, or in this case downtown to say look, there's opportunities to continue to push downtown forward,
continue to implement the downtown master plan that's been adopted by the Planning Commission in this body. So there's not an exact answer to do that. It's a science.
We do a lot of modeling. Okay, we go capture what you see on this screen. What is the possibility you see the circles there that kind of show where we see pockets of area of potential new growth.
But we didn't want to go really far south or let me give you an example, go all the way to the new northern bypass. We could do that and pick up the new North Village Town Center, which is 660,000 square feet of new retail that
you know, have a tax basis of about $300 a square foot annually, which not on the books. So it's not paying tax, we could win grab that. We don't think that's fair, and we could have just continue this North Beltline Greenway all the way up to that area.
We don't think that's fair to our education system nor Madison County. So we try to keep it concise in doing so. So we look at active projects that have been on the books, or ones that we know will move the needle from a tax base.
And we go say okay, what are those projects on the books that we can't ordinarily afford to do without new tax base, the bomb bronze center has been on the list for a very long time.
Our conferences, some of our biggest ones at USA and others are to the point that the community has grown, those conferences have grown, such that everybody that wants to have a booth or attend those conferences, and they have millions of dollars of economic impact annually to our general fund,
can't get to the conference. I think this past one in the spring they had 60 something vendors, which are defense contractors in different organizations that said we want to attend, we want to pay for a booth, and they said we're full.
Well now you're starting to have conversations, we love Huntsville, we've been coming here a long time, but we need to find a new venue. We need to find a venue to everyone who wants to participate in this national convention can actually participate.
And you look around us you have Birmingham who has made upgrades to the BJCC, Mobile is building a brand new civic center, Chattanooga has made expansions, Nashville, one of our big competitors, Savannah has just completed $600 million, Knoxville is looking.
So in and around us there are options to take the conferences that we have to other communities, which would be a significant hit to our general fund. I'm not saying that's the reason to go expand the VBC, I think we're at this inflection point.
You know it's our inflection point to have a civic center that holds graduations, occasional music and plays, and it really not be a convention center.
And you start looking at the investments with hotels and actually what we can continue to accelerate, we're at an inflection point, what do we want the Bonron Center to be?
So we started looking at this, it was a hard one to budget, it is a big number, but we said look we don't want it to be, we don't want to come to you with one project, that didn't make sense.
So really what we started doing is working the VBC and say okay, how tight can you get this estimate? Because these other four projects we're going to go do.
We would love to put the VBC in with those four projects and that's what we brought you.
Thank you. And now if you could answer the other questions that have come from the public, most of which were about the priorities, you've addressed the VBC, but other priorities that we have here and why this project is important for the community.
Yeah, so I had three notes and if I need to expand Councilmember, just point them out to me. So Mill Creek, so Mill Creek is under construction, so if you pass by Governor's Drive you'll actually see the site where the first building pad, so they're digging footings and foundations and you'll see steel start rising up as we get into the summer months.
So Phase 1 has moved forward. Actually we've released some renderings for Phase 2. McCormick, Ballin, Salazar, our third party partner is actually working on closing documents for financing for that second building.
So as we get into the third and fourth quarter of this year, you're going to see just a ton of new housing activity there. The other was affordability.
So one of the things I want to point out is actually in District 5 on Swancock Road, so our affordability manager, our planning department, our engineering department, kudos to those guys. They've been working really hard for the third straight year.
Huntsville is the second most affordable metro in the U.S. with a population of over 100,000. That's not just rent, that's actually for sale product also.
The case in point is we've changed the way we've allowed some lot costs and different things to keep pricing down. I've just been with an industry that's looking at Huntsville for the past two days.
We drove Swancock Road, Councilman Maris' district, and the beauty that they saw is the different price points going up at Swancock Road.
Great new subdivision, great looking full brick product, sign out front says starting the 200s across the street. Another says starting the low 3s. And then you've got bigger lots, 100 foot lots in housing.
So that's the result of our affordability manager working, community development, planning and engineering, and urban development all working together saying how do we move the needle in affordability.
We're starting to see that deployed on the ground. There's still a ton of work to do. So I'm proud of the effort that this team is doing on that.
And you can actually drive by and see the results by price points and things that are for sale. And we're getting national recognition due to those price points.
The last piece was public transit I had on my notes. So we do have a new public transit hub and they are working on new routes. So this project does it, this TIP district would not make any improvements to that transit facility because it is new.
It's relatively new and it was designed for the next 20 years. So we didn't see any public improvements needed.
As far as the new buses, if you've noticed, we went to a new longer bus. And a lot of that is funded through our MPO, some through our CalPlan, but also the Federal Transit Authority.
So we'll continue to expand that. We often hear more transit, more bus stops and locations. That's a totally separate conversation. We've had some of that.
In the chamber, actually last fall, started working with a lot of our industry in the Western Corridor. We've created 20,000 jobs out there. So we've started doing polls with actual employees who work at Mazda Toyota and Polaris and Amazon.
And this goes on and on and said, if we ran routes to this facility, would you take it? And if so, what would the times would you take it? Would you take it two days a week and what's your shift hour? So they're helping us populate all that interest in time so we can look at routes and get that back to public transit and see if it's a viable option for public transportation to some of our job centers, which has been one of the biggest requests for us to look at.
I believe we have another question for Mr. Mayor.
Not.
Actually, it's not a question.
I just wanted to say that my questions pertaining to the Commission aren't based on any objection. It's true. Be transparent. But given how some folks might feel that way, I do have to say that I agree with the mayor and my colleague, Mr. Cling, that we have a great relationship with him.
I'm working on projects right now with both Commissioner Haraway and Mr. Vant, Commissioner Vandiver had a great relationship with Mac and hope that I can establish one with Mr. Vaughn as well.
So it's not that I'm saying, oh, we shouldn't be doing this for the Commission. It's transparency. And yes, we work very well with the Madison County Commission. So just want to make that as a record.
Your clarification is noted. Are there any other concluding comments? In that case, the public hearing is now closed. Mr. Davis, thank you so much for your presentation. And we will look forward to seeing items come before this council for action and approval in the coming weeks.
Perfect. Council members, thank you for the open dialogue, the public hearing. We will move forward and continue the process that I laid out. We'll be back soon. Okay.
Thank you, sir. We do have one other public hearing that will follow our normal procedure. 9B is a public hearing in order to hear and consider and act upon all objections or protests, if any, for removal of a public nuisance at 4109 Burroughs Avenue, Southwest,
Alabama, and consideration of resolution in ordering abatement of a nuisance located at the same property. Mr. Irwin. Yes, Mayor Battle, Council members, Scott Irwin, Community Development Department. This public hearing is in reference to the property located at 4109 Burroughs Avenue,
Southwest. The property was in violation of the State Public Nuisance Act regarding junk. Community Development issued a notice to the property owner and interested parties. The property remains in violation. Community Development is seeking your authorization to abate this junk public nuisance.
The condition of the property is before you on the video screen. Property owners, as identified by the tax assessment records, were notified of the time and place where any objections may be heard involving the abatement of this junk public nuisance.
Council members, property owners are present with us tonight. I will note that improvements have been made, but it is not to the level that we need the improvements to be completed. Upon your approval of this resolution, we will continue to work with the property owners to allow them the opportunity to continue to complete the cleanup. However, failure by the owner to remove all of the junk and debris in a reasonable time will result in the City moving forward with our standard abatement process.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin. The public hearing on this item is now open. Is there anyone here who wishes to comment? Please come forward, state your name and address for the record.
Thank you, Mr. Irwin. Philip Cattle, District 4. Thank you.
Okay. Yes, we have Mr. Irwin, if you'd like to look at some of the pictures that we've taken for how we have worked to get these done.
Share those with Mr. Irwin in just a moment, please. Just go ahead with your comments and then you can share them.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay. I'm Philip Cattle. In District 4, we have made significant progress in the alleviation of any public nuisance at 4109 Burroughs Avenue. Here are the photos.
I would say it's a maximum of 10 weeks because of the limitations of the bulk pickup. I believe it's 10 cubic yards per week, but it may be less than that. We'll work diligently to clean this up.
So that's about it.
Thank you, sir. Is there anyone else who wishes to make comments regarding this item? The public hearing is now closed. Is there a motion to approve the resolution? Motion for Mr. Little, second from the chair. Discussion, council members. Mr. Kling?
I just want to make sure what we're talking about. Mr. Irwin, you would have the authority to, for lack of a better word, drop the hammer, but you're going to work with him to see if it's as reasonably quickly as possible getting cleaned up. Is that what you were asking for from the council?
Yes, sir, that is correct. So we were on site today looking. We would agree that there has been improvement, just not the level we need. So we'll work with the property owners to make sure things are done. However, there will be a time frame specific that we'll move forward with our property, our pavement process, if failure to complete it is not done.
Any other comments or questions from council? All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed? The resolution is approved and the motion passes.
Thank you, council members.
Thank you very much. Thank you, Mr. Irwin, for your willingness to work with the residents.
We'll now move on to public hearings to be set. We have several.
10A is a resolution to declare public nuisance located at 809 Cross Street, Northwest, Huntsville, Alabama to set a date for when objections will be heard. Is there a motion to set the date, the hearing for May 28, 2026?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second from Mr. Little. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any objections? The hearing is set for May 28.
10B is a resolution to set a public hearing to consider an appeal to the Liquor License Review Committee's decision to approve the application for a lounge retail liquor class one with entertainment to Bar Holdings LLC doing business as Tina's Lounge located at
12531 Memorial Parkway Southeast, Huntsville, Alabama 35803. Is there a motion to set the hearing for May 28, 2026? So moved. Motion for Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling. Is there any discussion? All in favor, please indicate. Aye.
Any opposed? The hearing is set for May 28, 2026.
Is Mr. Meredith still with us? Let the record show that Mr. Meredith has left the dais.
Is Mr. Meredith still present? 10C is a resolution to set a public hearing on the zoning of 1.33 acres of land lying on the north side of Winchester Road and west of Shields Road to Highway Business C4 District and instruction of an ordinance pertaining to the same. Is there a motion to set the hearing for June 25, 2026?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second from Mr. Little. Any discussion? All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed? The motion carries and the hearing is set for June 25, 2026.
10D is a resolution to set a public hearing on the rezoning of 47.19 acres of land lying on the south side of Swancock Road east of Rabbit Lane from Residence 1B District to Residence 2 District and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same. Is there a motion to set the hearing for June 25, 2026?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling. All in favor, please indicate. Aye.
Any opposed? The motion carries and the hearing is set for June 25, 2026.
And finally, 10E is a resolution to set a public hearing on a vacation of a portion of right of way at Greenbrier Road and Greenbrier Parkway and the introduction of a resolution consending to and the introduction of an ordinance vacating the rights of way pertaining thereto.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for June 25, 2026?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Little, second from Mr. Kling. All in favor, please indicate. Aye.
Any opposed? The motion carries and the hearing is set for June 25, 2026.
Brings us now to agenda related public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on matters relating to the specific content of items on the meeting agenda.
This individual has signed up to speak prior to the meeting when called, approached the microphone.
State your name and home address for N-City residents.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into dialogue with council members or City staff and from making comments regarding the good name and character of any individual.
We have one person signed up and that is Joy Johnson. Ms. Johnson, please come forward.
Endeavoring to be a thorn in your shoe.
I am Joy Johnson. So I live on West Harbor in Huntsville. Welcome.
I'm very I don't understand this item 20e.
Gift offer. Does that mean money?
And of all the industries that are being funded handsomely by the federal government,
why are my tax dollars going to go to the army to build somebody a residence?
I'm I'm just floored by that.
It you know, I'm.
I'm just so clipped.
I was once upon a time told by our mayor that we're trying to diversify and get out of being so dependent on the defense industry.
I have not actually seen that happening in the years since he sent me that card.
We are trying to diversify and get out of being so dependent on the defense industry.
There is no industry that produces less good for the citizenry.
Directly.
And what the question of what do you want the Von Von Center Center to be used for came up.
That's not what I want. The Von Braun Center to be used for.
I'd like to move away from the most poisonous industry in the on the planet.
In particular, our the United States defense industry is the biggest polluter single entity polluter in the world.
Also, I'd love to hear what the heck this item 20 AA is about.
And 20 AH, do we not already have enough guns?
What is what's this one about?
I personally from being here downtown in 2020 for the George Floyd stuff,
I kind of feel like we got we're bristling with enough guns already.
Just FYI. Thank you.
Thank you, Miss Johnson.
I think 20 E will certainly be addressed in our discussion.
We have no other agenda related public comments.
We will move on to comments by the mayor, Mayor Battle.
Thank you, Madam President.
For the record, we have the following two appointments,
the reappointment of Frank Nola to the Historic Preservation,
the Hustle Historic Preservation Commission for a six year term to expire May 4, 2032.
The reappointment of Adam Dero to the Air Pollution Control Board for a five year term to expire May 28, 2031.
That's all I have. Thank you.
Thank you, Mayor Battle. We'll move to council comments.
We'll begin with council member Bill Clinton.
Thank you, Madam President.
A lot of exciting, diverse events going on in the community and in the district over the last week or so.
It was my privilege to participate in the Historic Huntsville Preservation Commission awards
and to present a special award for 50 years of outstanding public service for historic preservation to Peter Lowe.
Peter is certainly a very deserving individual.
And additionally, I get to work with him on the Historic Preservation Commission.
And we're grateful for many great citizens such as Mr. Lowe and what they contribute to our city boards.
On Monday night, I went over to the McThormore Acres Neighborhood Association meeting,
and they were asking a lot of questions about police patrols and crime enforcement,
as well as about the upcoming Holmes Avenue Corridor Project and enjoyed the opportunity to visit with them.
Last week, myself and council member Meredith and I participated in the North Alabama International Trade Association
Global Policy and Strategy Luncheon that took place at the Jackson Center.
A lot of good contacts with people, again, a lot of county government people were there,
as well as people from both public and private from throughout North Alabama.
And this was a good learning experience for me, and I was very, very interested in hearing from people.
Earlier today, I participated with council member Little and Mayor Battle at the groundbreaking ceremony for the new Huntsville Middle School.
That's going to be apparently be ready for opening and being used within two years.
It's going to be a great plan, very, very ambitious, very much of an increase over the existing facility.
And I think it's going to be a great shot in the arm for schools in the community and what's coming for our school students.
Last night, I had a chance to see something very new that's come to Huntsville.
It's the Skyloom 60-foot tall light and sculpture artwork.
And it's located in John Hunt Park, and it's something that's you could it's best to see at night.
I had a chance to see it when while over there for the soccer match that took place.
It was officially unveiled last night.
And again, it's going to be something great.
I believe it can be seen from the parkway.
And, you know, it's just a new chapter in public artwork coming into the city of Huntsville and reaching into all areas of the community.
And it's very nice addition. Congratulations to the Arts Council for their great work that they went through to put that up.
A little bit of sad news. I am sorry to report the passing of John Lynch.
John was an elder senior member of West Lawn Church.
He was very active in the holiday homes community.
And again, he's a great person and one of those citizens that really are going to miss.
And I'm honored to have known him.
And I think this community was a much better place because of him.
As we talked about earlier tonight, there is going to be a special graduation ceremony as they're calling it to honor Microwave Dave.
And it's going to be taking place at the Bondron Center this Sunday from four to eight.
And at that time, Councilmember Little and I will be making presentations.
And I understand, Councilman Little, you may want to talk about it, but your brother actually played with Microwave Dave.
So that brings a little to that. I had a chance to know him, Microwave Dave, rather, when I was at public radio.
And he used to come in and sit up in the studios and do live concerts.
And I'm glad we could participate. We've got a lot of great teamwork that's taken place with city departments.
And I think this is going to be something that we're going to be proud of, recognition of one of our great citizens and his mark and what he has meant to our community.
And, Madam President, that's all I have. Thank you.
For your comments, Mr. Kling, we'll now hear from Councilmember David Little.
Thank you, Madam President. Back at the end of April, had a great meeting with the Cove Area Citizens Action Group. They put together a town hall.
A lot of questions around the school system. So we had Dr. Sutton and Holly McCarty on hand, which was great.
Also had County Commissioner Hill and representatives from Dale Strong's office there.
So had a really good meeting. A lot of their questions and concerns answered for things happening out that way.
And then, like Mr. Kling said, got to attend the groundbreaking for Huntsville Middle School.
When I went there, it was about a 10-year-old school. And now it's getting torn down. So that kind of puts things in perspective.
But it'll be a great new addition. And I think a lot of people will be happy, really, with a lot of the new traffic improvements around there that's going to come with the new school.
And then got to sit in with the Mayor's Youth Council today and listen to these bright young students share some policy ideas for things they have, ranging from local community involvement leadership to composting.
It's interesting. A lot of kids get their lunch at school and don't eat at all.
So they're trying to find better uses for the food instead of going to the landfill or the power plant. So that was great.
And yeah, looking forward to, obviously, hate that it has to happen, but the graduation program for Dave is going to be special, be a part of that. He played at our wedding.
And I think my wife walked up to him at concerts in the park and said, do you play weddings? He said, sure.
And so a lot of great memories with him and obviously my brother and he go way back. So that'll be special for me personally to be involved to be a part of that.
And then finally, special thanks to Public Works, Engineering, Hunchel Police and Community Development for their, as usual, responsiveness to citizen concerns over the last few weeks.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Little. We'll now hear from Councilmember John Meredith.
I think for the first time ever, I'm going to yield my time.
Thank you, sir. And we'll move on to Councilmember Michelle Watkins.
Good evening, everyone. I want to say congratulations to the graduates of Drake State Calhoun Community College, UH and Alabama A&M University.
Major accomplishments and just want to recognize them for it. Quick fact.
We had a celebrity's daughter graduate from Alabama A&M on Friday. Dion Sanders daughter, Shalomi, graduated from Alabama A&M and Dion and the brothers, all of them were in attendance.
So exciting news from the campus next week on Thursday and Friday.
Huntsville City Schools will have their graduation. And I'm excited about their go Jags.
Thank you, Sarah, Caroline King, Kathy Jordan Johnson, Zach McWhorter, Dr. Sudden and all the employers who participate in the job fair that we have for students on this past Monday at the Huntsville Center for Technology.
I was really impressed at how the employers showed up and were ready to hire some students for the summer. So thank you.
I want to thank Scott Irwin, Shane Davis, Chris McNeese, Sam, Sarah, Lily and Brian Walker. They answer the phone me every time I call. Thank you.
You do a great job. I also want to thank the Cary Hills Community Center staff.
They set up for my district drop drop in that we had this past Tuesday.
And I want to thank them so much for doing that. They're always so courteous and I appreciate that so much.
That's all I have. Thank you, Miss Watkins.
I hosted a town hall this past week. I was very successful.
I want to thank all of those who made time to attend, particularly James Vandiver from our planning staff who presented the city's development review.
He always does it uniquely with a uniquely D3 focus. And I know that takes him a lot of extra time to drill down that far, but it was very informative and gave everybody a really good look at where development was headed.
We look forward to hearing more of that again at the June 1st joint meeting that we have with the school system.
Where Mr. Vandiver and Mr. Davis will both take a look at that development review doing something similar for each of the districts to look at growth, impact on the schools, and where we are going as a community and how are we moving to accommodate that growth.
So many thanks to everybody who helped, particularly Lily and Sarah on our council staff who were helpful in pulling all of that together.
Everybody who came to that meeting also got to see that work is progressing at the Sandra Moon Center. It's starting to actually look like it may finish someday.
We are still targeting an August opening. We have the first performance there scheduled for October 1st. So everybody will be moved in and ready for that performance.
And we look forward to that work continuing to go forward. I held a meeting this week with Lyle Voyles who is the president of the Huntsville Council of Neighborhood Associations and also a great advocate for the Chappie community.
We met with Chris McNeese to talk about existing city ordinances on curbs and gutters and how we can do a better job enforcing those ordinances.
We hope to have a citywide campaign in the summer regarding grass in the gutters and keeping gutters clear and storm drains clear.
And then in the fall with leaves, keeping the gutters and clear of leaves. It is the homeowners responsibility to keep the gutters in front of your property clear so that stormwater can flow and that benefits everyone.
And finally had the opportunity yesterday with Mr. Kling to attend the governor's address to the chamber hosted the governor's update and a phrase I counted four times.
She said we need to keep our foot on the gas. And that made me think of what we're doing here in Huntsville.
We are keeping the foot on the gas and keeping it between the lines.
And the presentation you heard tonight on TIF-9 is just one of the ways we continue to move forward and continue to make progress.
And that concludes my comments. But I have noticed that we have at least I think two scouts here with us tonight.
If you would like to come to the microphone, please. You weren't expecting this were you?
Introduce yourselves and tell us about you're here working on a badge.
Tell us what level you are and what badge you're working on.
I think you're working on a communications badge. So, you know, this will give you an opportunity to communicate. Just come to this this podium right here.
We're glad you're here. You're here, by the way.
My name is Matthew Danson. I am with the scout group of.
Police Spirit School, troop 361 and I'm doing this for my communication merit badge.
And see there, I bet you can check something on the badge up because you spoke at a city council meeting.
I am Blake Danson. I'm doing the same as him.
Communications also. And were you all were you all on the tour that I did with you with your with your troop?
Okay, well, because I did one with your truth. Wonderful. Welcome.
We are glad that you are here. Thank you. Thank you.
And keep going until you get your eagle and don't stop.
Good. So close. Very good.
Okay, let the record show Mr. Meredith has returned and we will proceed now with the rest of our business meeting.
14 a is a resolution authorizing expenditures for payment.
I move for authorization and approval of expenditures in the amount of fifty nine million one hundred ninety six thousand six hundred thirteen dollars and sixty four cents.
Second, Mr. Meredith makes the motion. Mr. Little makes the second. All in favor, please indicate.
I impose the motion carries and Mr. Meredith, I believe we have a report on the May 28th meeting.
Is that correct? Oh, yes, not tonight. Right. Not tonight. May 28th me. Very good. Thank you.
Fourteen B is an ordinance approving appropriations, goods or services for District one council improvement funds.
Chairman's approval. Second. Second from Miss Watkins. Miss Watkins, would you like to share with us the good work you are doing?
Yes, these council funds will go to the school's foundation.
And this is for the purpose of teachers in District one get national board certification. I think it's very important for us to offer that support to the school's foundation as well as the teachers.
Thank you, Miss Watkins. Any other comments, questions? All in favor, please indicate. I oppose. Motion carries.
Fourteen C is an ordinance approving appropriations, goods or services for District two council improvement funds.
Motion for Mr. Little second second from Mr. Kling. Mr. Little, would you like to share with us the use of these funds? Yes, ma'am.
This is a ten thousand dollar fund to our donation to porch.
That's five points to advance public and cultural enrichment, fosters community engagement, supports local creative development and connects homes for residents with music, arts and mental wellness resources.
Thank you. Any questions or comments? All in favor, please indicate. I oppose. Motion carries.
We have no board. Surprisingly, no board appointments to be voted on and no board appointment nominations. Are there any nominations from the floor?
Seeing none, we will move forward then with item seventeen.
Seventeen A is a resolution authorizing the mayor to approve adding a line item to the fiscal year twenty six electric capital budget in the amount of five hundred thousand dollars and to the fiscal year.
Twenty seven electric capital budget in the amount of five point five million dollars to fund project Gemini.
Is there a motion to approve motion for Mr. Merida? Second for Mr. Little.
Oh, so we have a presentation from Honsley Utilities. Yeah, Chris Jones, chief operating officer, Honsley Utilities. Welcome.
Thanks for having me tonight. This resolution is for capital funding needed to construct a new substation to interconnect the solar development near Triana or we call Project Gemini.
As you guys recall, on April 9th, City Council approved a land lease for the project. Madison County also approved the same land lease.
Those are really the two final hurdles to get this project moving. So the total cost to build the substation is six million dollars.
The five hundred thousand dollars needed for this year would be for engineering, design and site work.
The remainder remaining five point five million would be for material equipment and construction.
We anticipate completion in the fall of twenty twenty seven. And as you may recall, the solar developer needed to move somewhat quickly due to the tax credits expiring.
So that means we need to move somewhat quickly as well to keep up. And I'd be happy to answer any questions. Thank you. Questions for Mr. Jones?
Questions. I think the question that always gets asked, is this going to raise rates for any of our customers? No, ma'am.
This will actually lower the cost of energy and it will save us with some demand charges from TVA.
Terrific. Thank you so much. All in favor, please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries. Thank you. Thank you, sir.
We have several legal department items and transactions.
Section A is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of a utility and drain adjudgment between lots 14 and 15 West Park subdivision 205 and 215 West Park Loop. Is there a motion to approve? Motion to approve. Motion for Mr. Meridith. Second for Mr. Little. Any questions? All in favor, please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries.
Section B is an ordinance authorizing the vacation of a portion of utility drain adjudgment lot 29 block one. Governor's Bend subdivision 2266. Governor's Bend Road. Motion to approve. Motion for Mr. Meridith. Second for Mr. Little. Any questions? All in favor, please indicate aye. Any opposed? Motion carries.
Section 18C has been deleted at the request of the sponsor. We will move on to 19 unfinished business items for action. 19A is an ordinance renaming the portion of Cleveland Avenue from Meridian Street to Church Street to microwave Dave Way.
Move for approval. Motion for Mr. Kling. Second for Mr. Little. Any comments? Discussion? All in favor, please indicate aye. Opposed? Motion carries. I'm sorry. If I can. I know there are folks in the audience that have been wanting us to rename a certain street and we have not done it because there are people on that street.
There are occupants on this particular stretch of street. So what is the difference? Why are we doing this and not the other? I know the answer but just for the publics. Okay. Mr. Kling, you had. Yeah. There are. There were identified to be six business people involved and six business people involved.
And they all came forward and said they wanted this to happen. So that is why it's being done. It was in fact in a way I believe it was partially or co initiated by two of those business people and so that's why it's being done.
Mr. Nunez, do you have anything to add to that? No, I echo the same sentence. These properties were assessed. If that was a valid question, thank you for asking it. Good answer. Any other questions? I do have questions but not for Mr. Nunez. Thank you, Mr. Nunez. It's a really comment.
I know that there are some citizens that are here as well as some that are not here that have expressed their concern about a road that they feel is derogatory to one of our friends.
And so I think that you know how quickly we got this done. Let's look at getting it done as well. And I think that was the point that Mr. Merritt. Yeah, but I just want to be. I want to reiterate myself but still have the floor.
So I do want them to know that we are looking at it. We have not forgotten. And so when can we look at getting this done and who would we talk to to get the step started. That's that's probably that Shane's. Talk about it.
And not to take away from from this action. All in favor please indicate. Any opposed motion carries and this presentation will be made at the May 17th graduation event. 19 B is an ordinance to name the dog park located at I five sixty five and Pratt Avenue known as the downtown dog with spot to the microwave.
Dave dog spot motion to motion from Mr. Meredith second from Mr. Little any conversation question with regard to this. All in favor please indicate. I pose motion carries.
19 C is an ordinance to amend ordinance and again that that that action will also be presented at the May 17th event. 19 C is an ordinance to amend ordinance number 94-523 which establishes precinct boundary lines for municipal election motion to Mr. Meredith second from this little miss Edwards.
Good evening. Could you please share with us what we're doing here. Good evening council mayor battle Shandrick Edwards city clerk. Tonight I'm presenting an amendment to ordinance number 94-523 which pertains to the election precinct boundary lines within the city of Huntsville.
First I want to thank each of you. We had an opportunity to meet a few weeks ago and your feedback was much appreciated and we are taking those into consideration ahead of each election cycle. But I also want to thank Joel Watson.
He's our assistant city attorney who for the last three months has been assisting me along with Amy Keenum our GIS manager and Rachel Cunningham our GIS specialist. They wrote the entire 166 page document to update this ordinance.
So I do want to thank our GIS department tonight. Like much of what we do we are driven by a state statute and this is no different. Code section 11-46-23 says that the municipal governing body may at its discretion adjust our boundary lines and we must make no such adjustment within three months of any
municipal election. So your consideration tonight is very important. We know there is an election coming up August 25th for districts 2, 3 and 4. And should you consider this ordinance tonight as the municipal clerk I must file this within five days with Madison County.
So while we are doing this it is important that we establish a baseline for our citywide voting precincts for a number of reasons. We know since 1994 there has been substantial growth within the city of Huntsville but also we want to ensure that our election process is efficient and that our voters are going to the most convenient location within the district.
And lastly it is important here that we collaborate with Madison County. We have talked about the county a lot tonight. I have spoken with the probate judge, the board of registrars, the circuit clerk all this week ahead of tonight because I did not want to surprise them with our changes with the primaries going on.
So before I get into the updates I do want to stress that any change we make here they do not impact Madison County elections and I think it is important that I say that now because the primary election is next week.
Tonight I will say alternate polling locations a lot and I wanted to explain I know the council had this question and I thought it was important for the public to hear it as well. First like I said Madison County they administer all county, state, and federal elections.
I am responsible for just the municipal election and that's important for the record.
But Madison County does assign alternate polling locations where a voter may vote at a location that is not within the city limits for the county. And to break that down a little bit one great example is Hampton Cove.
And if they are in the primaries next week they may go to Hampton Cove Church of Christ, but for the municipal election they will go to an alternate location which is River Tree Church, and that's important because by statute, our voters must vote within the city
limits. So you asked the question I thought maybe the public should hear that as well. We have 31 alternate polling locations out of the 70 from Madison County so it's important for the record that you understand this has been going on for three decades.
Alternate polling locations is not new. I talked to the county we kind of dug a little bit to find out the history and this has been going on for almost 30 years.
Thank you to GIS for this map. This is a great map that outlines all 39 of our precincts. And I know you're probably looking out West what's going on over there and 104 and we're going to talk about district five, honestly, most of the presentation,
a lot of the growth that we have experiences out West, and I know district five for the record does not have an election this year but because we're establishing a baseline for all five of your districts.
So it's important that we go ahead and we talk through the changes for all five districts, but we will talk a little bit more about the West, a little bit later in the presentation but this gives a great snapshot of all 39 across the city of Huntsfield.
So, the first thing is we have 39 precincts but I only have six adjustments for your approval tonight. So we aren't talking about all 39 most of what exists today is not changing.
So I want to say that, especially for districts to three and four. You won't hear me speak on districts to three or four much tonight we do have one update that we're going to talk about in district three but for the most part, a lot of it is in five and in
six. So, we're going to talk about that in a second. But the first adjustment that I am asking you for consideration tonight. Chase Park Church of Christ is an alternate polling location that is not within the city limits.
It's on with Chester Road. And as you look at my maps to the left, you'll see the original and as it exists today. And thank you to GIS for this on the right, you'll see the change.
So, this church is not in the city limits. We have been utilizing it and we want to make sure that we're making adjustments where we need to to make it right.
I am removing Chase Park Church of Christ with your approval and reassigning those voters to Alabama A&M University. That is their next closest precinct.
I'm going to ask how many residents are affected by this change?
There are 32 households. And if you look at the census calculation times 1.9 to get the voting age population within those households, there's about 61 voters that could be impacted with this change, not major.
We're not going to be able to do that, luckily, but we do have to ensure that we're presenting to you the number of voters that could be impacted here.
In addition to the 32 households, there are some apartments off of Winchester that are within the city limits and it's landing Huntsville and Arbor's at Morris Mill.
We're looking at about 344 units. And when you look at the total voting age population for this change, we're looking at about 715 voters.
So that's a huge change. So we're going to go to Alabama A&M.
The second adjustment that I want to talk through tonight, precinct 56 and 77 were never assigned an alternate.
The area on Highway 72 is newly annexed areas. We know we have grown out west, but we also know in District 1, we've expanded as well and we need to truly look at all of our annexations and tonight's ordinance does take into account all annexations through April 30.
And that's why we're waiting to now to do that because if we were going to establish a baseline, we want to make sure we took into consideration all of our annexations.
This newly annexed area will be assigned to Hope Valley Bible Church on Highway 72.
But what I want you to look at the small piece of precinct 77. Currently, there are no residents, but we do have one planned subdivision being developed there, but there are no residents at this time.
The lower portion precinct 56 and 77 that's flood plain and industrial park so again, no residents, so very minimal impact with this change.
We thought it was important to go ahead and establish an assignment though, should there be residents with the subdivision being developed.
This adjustment is Morgan County and Marshall County. Like I mentioned earlier, we have expanded across four counties, and we have never assigned Morgan and Marshall County a precinct.
There are no residents affected with this change but should there ever be residents in this area, they will go to precinct 21 which is Farley Community Church, that is the closest precinct for those potential voters.
There's a lot going on with this one, I want to make sure that I break this down. This is district five. First, I want you to look at precinct 78 in the red and 84 in the purple area, they were originally assigned to precinct 54 Sherwood.
However, many of the residents were concerned about this because they were driving all the way to Sherwood Baptist Church and if you look all the way on Madison Pike, they were bypassing precinct 101 which is wall highway Baptist Church.
And I got a lot of calls in 2024 on this but unfortunately with the timing, we could not make that adjustment but I did talk to those voters and said we will look at this when time come around and this was our opportunity to make this right.
This will save them, I would say probably 17 minutes with our traffic at this time in that area to be honest it doesn't seem far but you know after five, it could potentially be about a 20 minute drive that could save them and their home is right there, bypassing wall highway Baptist Church.
So, we are really excited about this change and we hope you consider it tonight.
This change would affect 1056 households and if you look at the voting age population we're looking at a little over 2000 single family households. There are several apartment complexes as well.
I just want to make sure those blue triangles actually but look like dots to you that indicates residents, and we use garbage pickups to determine the count that I've been going through tonight.
Again there are several apartments, cottages at Indian Creek 56 units, Highland Point 292 units and Highfield at Madison 258 units.
And if they were all occupied, we are looking at a little over 3000 voting age populations affected if the units were occupied in all the homes.
And I know that seems like a lot but we would make every effort to add machines and poll workers. And honestly this location is very well ran but we will make sure we add all the necessary resources.
And I do believe the voters will be very happy.
So, we have our assessment number five precinct 70 in red very tiny at the top of your screen. You should see that up there next to precinct 51. They were assigned to Sherwood, and you can see Sherwood at the bottom of the screen again off of old Madison Pike.
And the area was assigned to 51, which is West Huntsville Church of Christ, and we want to eliminate voter confusion because this neighborhood was split. And we did not want the neighborhood some going to Sherwood, and then the other half going to West Huntsville
Church of Christ. So for consistency, we are asking to reassign that small portion of precinct 70 to also be assigned to precinct 51 West Huntsville Church of Christ. And this is the same as the adjoining area in limestone county.
So it's really for consistency.
The number of residents affected here we're looking at 207 households no apartments for a total of 393 voting age population. Again, we take into account the census calculation when we get the total number of voters.
This area again we're looking at district five. There is a very small portion of precinct 89 in red at the top of your screen, which was originally assigned to precinct 104 which is Daystar, and it was not contiguous with the rest of the area on
day 72. And so what we will be doing here is reassigning those voters to also go to precinct 54, but they were driving from 72 all the way to Daystar, when most of the neighboring community was going to Sherwood.
Precinct 63, which is in the purple area was split between 104 Daystar and alternate precinct 54 Sherwood, and we will reassign those voters to Sherwood, and this is a better solution because we really need to balance out Daystar and Sherwood.
Right now, we know there's a lot of growth in district five and we're trying to balance out the number of voters so that we're not overcrowding Daystar.
And as I mentioned about precinct 63 it looks like a lot of coverage, but most of that is redstone arsenal, and we do not have a large number of eligible voters in this area.
So single single family homes impacted and if you look at the purple area where the kind of the A for the residents and those apartments. That's all this affected here, Alexandria apartments, 258 units, Arch Street apartments 278 Madison Park 308 packs in
250 units, and we're looking at a little over 1100 units in a little over 2200 voting age population affected again, most of this is redstone arsenal.
So that's it for my updates last thing I just want to stress again, as you've seen there was very minimal changes to districts to three and four with the election coming up. Honestly they're very stable.
There was really no major concerns in districts to three and four with the exception of ensuring that we address Morgan and Marshall County.
So what you consider tonight again do not in any way impact the county elections, specifically the primaries but our changes will never impact the county and what you consider tonight will go into effect beginning August 25 of this year.
Any changes that we make I will continue to work with GIS and the county so that we can send out new voter cards. They will come from not just my office but by law, the Board of Registrars, they must send new cards out, we will pay for that.
We will also print cars as well just to make sure we have covered our bases and the word has gotten out for all the changes tonight. We will continue to monitor annexations ahead of every election cycle to make sure that we come before you with any
additional changes.
I want to map back up one more time I just want you to know out west we will continue. There's still work to be done, I will tell you that with Sherwood 54 Daystar 10451 West Huntsville Church of Christ.
One other thing and we've talked about this Councilman Meredith we do have a new recreation center that in 2028 because we own and operated, I don't feel that there will be any issues with adding our recreation center as a new polling location that will allow us to alleviate
some of the pressures off of Daystar. And so we will look at doing that and I'll talk more about that with John Hamilton.
I'm glad to answer any questions that you have. Council members, the time is yours for discussion Mr. Meredith. Thank you Madam President on the cards, at least going to district five since we are not in an election cycle.
Will the cards be sent upon your filing this or will they be held until 28 election cycle for us. I think right now with other elections going on and I think it's most appropriate to wait until it's closer to the time.
Right now, it I mean two years, we don't know if they'll be able to even find it so I think it's best to wait until the beginning of 2028.
I would support that. Okay. Not that I have a vote in that but I would support that. And also, the West Huntsville rec center. I too have had some conversation, assuming your conversations have at least included, Judge barger of that being a potential
named polling location later so we do anticipate that and hope it works out but I talked to his office this week.
I talked to Megan foster his elections administrator, and she was happy to hear she said we need it as well can we please consider it so we look forward to offering that to them as well.
Great. Thank you very much. The work phenomenal. If I could get a copy of the slides that would be great. But kudos. Did a great job. Thank you. Thank you so much. A lot of work to do in district five but it's good work.
Well, you know I'll let you know when you, I think you have it but it's really nice to be able to say you did a great job. Thank you.
Any other questions or comments.
Mr. Blank redundant but playing off of Councilman Meredith, you're going to be doing communications to the voters and districts to three and fours about the changes that have taken place prior to August 25.
So, there are actually no voters that were impacted that we need to send cards because in district three it was Morgan and Marshall there are no residents and then in two and four, we didn't make any good I just want you to put that out there so we wouldn't get
any bad calls over the weekend about that. Absolutely and I'll repeat that we did not make any major changes to districts to three or four district three changes there were no residents at this time.
But, you know, we do know that could come, and we will address it at that time but I don't foresee that happening ahead of your election.
I would just make one observation that occurred to me as we were going through the slides municipal elections know have notoriously low voter turnout.
And so, I'm thinking, this will maybe, if you don't have to go all the way to Sherwood Park if you can vote closer to home. It may actually help voter turnout.
But that might be an unintended consequence here that it would be a very good thing. And you're right. I really want to push our voter turnout to increase. We are at approximately 7% our unfortunate I hate to say this, our overall turnout in 24 was less than one precinct
and we will expect the voters. We need to do better. And we are a large municipality and I think we can do that so this this may help that. So thank you for that. Thank you for the work, Miss Edwards you and your teammate Mr Watson.
Miss Kenan and all the whole GIS team. This was a challenging project, and y'all did a great job.
Thank you for your consideration. So, all in favor please indicate. The motion carries. Thank you again for your good work. Thank you. 19 D is an ordinance to amend Chapter three alcoholic beverages Article three of the code of ordinances of the city of Huntsville, subsection
three of section three dash one three three hours of sale and operation motion to approve motion for Mr Merritt second for Mr little Mr Nunez please help us understand what we're doing. Good evening council members Thomas Nunez manager planning and zoning services.
This is an action that will adopt and change the hours of sales and operations, particularly for our special retailers or special retailers are those entities like our public authority similar to like the airport, our museums our state parks.
We have some requests over time in regards to when alcoholic beverage sales could actually commence the current ordinance read at the louse at 10am. This will adjust that time and allow those particular authorities to therefore operate earlier or sooner.
Over the years we've gotten complaints or not complaints but request in itself from residents who have anxiety or other issues as they travel and fly. They would like to have a beverage or so and then consume many of our other national airports also have this same play
thing in place. So we've deemed it appropriate to bring that to you. Although it talks about special retailers I've give you some some some some cover in this action there are other special retailers that are like event places.
Those places go through special exception and border zoning adjustment so there's caveats that we can control the hours of operation for those. So they don't they although they're special retailers they don't fall within this ordinance because of the border zone
adjustment and special exception process that can control the hours of operation for those instances. This will strictly focus on the museums, state parks, and public authorities are that hold a special retailers license.
Questions for Mr. Nunez. Thank you Madam President. You said the current start time is 10am. What are you what would it was your request to it would change to 6am so there's a prohibited time from 2am to 6am.
The current is 2am to 10am. And then on Saturdays and Sundays there are also a request of 2am to 6am. Sounds great. Thank you very much. Madam President any other comments or questions.
All in favor please indicate. Motion carries. Thank you Mr. Nunez. 19E is an ordinance annexing 2.47 acres of land lying on the south side of old highway 20 east of Greenbrier Parkway. Is there a motion to approve motion to approve Mr. Mayor second from Mr. Little.
As council members as you said this is located south side of old highway 20 and east of Greenbrier Parkway petition is seeking to annex for city services is overall 2.47 acres. The proposal is for a office use this is near Mazda Toyota is just to the north by northeast and also to the south as Amazon plant one located just south by southeast.
Questions for Mr. Nunez. Oh Mr. Merritt. No no. All in favor please indicate. Motion carries. Thank you council members council members this brings us to item 20. We've been going for two hours now and so I would propose we take a break but before we do.
Are there any items that anyone wishes to hold and that will give the administration a chance to get the part appropriate department heads a head up so any items anyone wishes to hold for 20 miss what 20 D. G. M. N. Q. R. T.
A. A. A. B. A. C. A. D. A. F.
Any other items anyone wishes to hold. I would like to add 20 E.
That's it just 20 and I would add item 20 I and 20 J. So items to be held item D item E item G item A. I item J item N. M. N. Q. R. T. Double A double B double or A. C. Double A. A. B. A. C. A. D. A. F.
So item 20. I would like to add plus five items. Did I capture everything looks like we are going to need that break so I would propose that we take a break and reconvene.
We'll just do all of that at the same time when we come back.
So a break until 742.
All right, everybody, we're about ready to start.
All right, it is 742 and this session of the Huntsville City Council meeting on May 14th
is called back to order.
And we will begin our work on paragraph 20, new business items for consideration or action.
Council members have requested that items D, E, G, I, J, M, N, Q, R, T, AA, AB, AC,
AD, and AF are to be held.
Does anyone have anything else they want to hold?
Is that good?
Did we capture all of them?
And the Chair moves for consolidation of items 20A, B, and C, 20F, 20H, 20K and L, 20O and
P, 20S, 20U to Z, 20AE and 20AG to AM.
Is there a second?
All in favor indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
Those items are consolidated and approved.
And we will now consider items that Council members have chosen to remove for separate
consideration.
We will begin with 20D.
20D is a resolution authorizing the Mayor to enter into an asset purchase and contract
termination agreement among the City of Huntsville, Huntsville Venue Group, F&B, LLC and Huntsville
Venue Group, Empathy at our LLC for the City's purchase from F&B of its food and beverage
concession assets used at Orion Empathy and the Food Village together, the Orion, and
amended and restated operating agreement between the City and HVGA respecting the operation
and management of Orion and various other related documents and actions.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from the Mayor, a second from Mr. Kling.
Mr. Hamilton.
Good evening, Council Members.
John Hamilton, City Administrator.
Thank you for the opportunity to discuss this.
One of the things, and I will apologize up front that this is a fairly long presentation,
but I think it's necessary because for a couple different reasons.
One, what's before you while we see it as a good new story for the City financially,
it's also very, very complicated.
Some of that complication is because the nature of what we're doing here, it kind of has multiple
actions all tied to each other.
But also one of the things I've found just engaging with citizens and even sometimes
with city staff talking about operations at the Orion, there's aspects of it that I don't
think is well understood.
So I want to hopefully tonight help educate folks and give a little bit of understanding
about how this piece of public infrastructure is operated, but then also obviously go through
with you the details of what we're asking you to approve tonight.
So this affects really kind of all aspects of the way in which we financially perform
at the Orion.
So first off, when we started back, it's really kind of 2018 and 2019 moving forward on developing
amphitheater for our community, we did a lot of study of how other amphitheaters are used
around the Southeastern US in particular and really identified some things that we want
to do a little bit differently here.
We found a model in St. Augustine, Florida actually that replicated some of the things
we wanted to do.
And what that really represented there is as you see on that chart, broken out activity
in two different categories.
A lot of amphitheaters are built in communities and they put on 18, 20, 30 big concerts a
year and every other day out of the year they're just sit there dark.
And we decided we wanted this piece of public infrastructure to do more for our community
than just that.
Well, we certainly wanted that and we've been pretty successful in attracting some concerts
that otherwise would not have come to Huntsville.
We also want to use it for other kinds of cultural enrichment, recreational, even fitness
opportunities for our communities.
That's that second category you see there and have been pretty successful in doing that.
Now one aspect of that and it's when I talk about the financials, that second category,
those community and cultural events are generally free to the public or very, very low cost.
And they aren't, we're not setting out to make money off of them.
They aren't intended, they aren't structured to be financially profitable on their own.
Not really dissimilar to a rec center.
When we build a rec center and then offer opportunities for people to do fitness and
recreation, other kinds of things.
We don't, you know, when we opened the West Huntsville Rec Center, we didn't say, hey,
we're going to turn the profit off this.
That wasn't, that's the ROI we're looking for in that rec center.
It's really quality of life and it's opportunities for our community.
And so we wanted the amphitheater to perform similarly for those community and cultural
event categories.
We certainly expect the major concerts in the aggregate to be profitable.
There's a big concert that comes in and a promoter has misread the demand and it's
not profitable.
And those losses are shared oftentimes between the venue and the promoter.
But in the aggregate, our concerts have been financially profitable and we certainly expect
that to continue on into the future.
So we've seen in terms of the use and the impact that we believe has happened in our
community from a quality of life perspective, we've seen the Orion do exactly what we set
out to do and we expect it to get even better in future years.
But what's somewhat complicated and sometimes confusing for folks is how is it that we operate
it?
And I want to emphasize, we'll start with the stuff there in the oval shape and the
egg shape.
A lot of folks, because we have contracted with a private company to operate on our behalf,
I encounter people who think it's a private venue and it is not.
I want the citizens to know that they own the amphitheater.
That is a city building that is city-owned land.
Now we've done it through the PBA and we'll talk about that a little bit, but the PBA
is an extension of the city government.
The citizens of Huntsville own that.
The same way they own rec centers, the same way they own the city hall, the same way they
own the VBC and some of the museum facilities and things, they own that asset.
We have chosen to operate it with a private company.
Now how does that compare to say, say, like the VBC?
The VBC is also not operated by a city department while the city owns the physical asset.
Decades ago now, the city decided to have a volunteer board, go hire employees and operate
on our behalf.
But financially, it is the city's asset.
It's just operated on our behalf by that board and we have museums and other things that
are very, very similar.
We could have done that with the Orion.
We could have said, hey, we'll appoint a volunteer board and have them hire employees and operate
it the same way the VBC is.
In that particular case, in our judgment, we felt that bringing in a company that had
some of the experience and the relationships that they have in the music industry, it would
be valuable to rely on around that type of relationship to operate it.
But when we talk about the asset, we own it.
We the city own it.
The citizens of Huntsville own it.
And when we talk about it financially, I hear people talk about HVG's budget.
HVG, Huntsville Venue Group, Amphitheater is that company.
They don't have their own budget.
They manage our city budget.
So as a component of our general fund, when Ms. Smith brings you the budget every September,
it along with lots of other things, obviously, that's buried into that budget, you are proving
the financial package that we do out at the Orion.
So that is our money.
When it makes a dollar, it's the citizens' dollar.
When they lose a dollar, it's the citizens' dollar.
So that I think is important to understand.
Now, as we move forward in the development of the Orion, there was a proposal brought
forward, and Mr. Davis led, as he does with all of our economic development projects,
led pursuing an opportunity to partner with the company.
Now it's a sister company to Huntsville Venue Group, Amphitheater, but known as Huntsville
Venue Group Food and Beverage, LLC, but a separate company.
But it is definitely related at the corporate level to our operator to actually do private
investment and private development adjacent to the Amphitheater.
And I'll get you some satellite thoughts here to kind of help with the real estate aspect
of this.
But we entered into a development agreement.
We'll leave the city into a development agreement and a ground lease with them so they could
do that development.
And as a component of that, they then had to enter into the concessions contract to
run all the food and beverage operations in and around the Orion.
Some of that arrangement and the necessity to do it that way is driven by state laws
that relates to alcohol licensing, the way that campus functions.
You can only have one alcohol license.
So the opportunity to split it up into multiple entities did not exist.
And so we needed to have a single concessions contract.
So in simple terms, that's the structure and we'll go into more detail on it now.
So the picture to the left shows you the site.
I've broken it up into three sub areas, but if you all those three areas together, that's
in the color polygons is the parcel of land owned by the PBA and leased to the city.
Now in the specifically in that red area, the amphitheater areas, it's labeled there.
The PBA also constructed the amphitheater and they are technically the owners.
So with any time that we do a piece of public infrastructure through the public building
authority, they have to actually hold the deed to it and then lease it back to the city.
And so we lease it at whatever their debt service payment is for the 20 years.
So we did borrow some money for this and that's on a 20 year debt cycle like all of our debt
is.
So PBA owns the area in red, leased it to the city and then we entered into an operating
agreement with HBG amphitheater.
And as noted there, they on our behalf entered into that concessions contract with HBG food
beverage.
Dairy and blue is the area that's been referred to as the food village.
That area again, owned by the PBA and leased to the city.
And then as part of that development agreement, we subleased that area to them.
What we subleased to them was vacant dirt and they then built a couple of buildings
and a lot of other improvements, 100% at their private investment.
So they own those improvements that are on that dirt.
The ground is leased from us, but they own all of the physical improvements and all the
work that's occurred inside that area.
The third area, what we call remaining area, there's also some references to it as green
space.
Green space is kind of a forested extension of Apollo's park.
We sometimes refer to it as Apollo South.
Nothing about tonight changes that.
That's just parkland.
When there's not an event going on, the gates are open.
People go in there and walk down the woods and stuff, but it does not really tie to the
operations of the Orion and it's not in any way affected by tonight's actions.
So you see this again and in real simple terms, sometimes I do the bottom line up front with
your approval tonight, what happens if the, hold on a second.
That happens.
Okay.
That was more complicated than it needed to be.
So essentially as we go through this tonight, what we're asking you to do is to buy out
all the physical assets and then buy out the contract they have so that we can absorb the
financial aspects of that business fully into the Orion and we'll go through the numbers
on that.
So first, what were the terms that they had?
They have a sublease that was 10 years plus a five year renewal.
So there were 12 years total remaining on their rights to the ground lease.
The rent for that ground lease was 7% of the gross revenues on the food and beverage operations.
And so we have, in terms of the profit and loss statement for the Orion, as we track
their financials, there was some money coming in from food and beverage, but what we now
know from four years of experience and just seeing how things have developed, we really
need to improve that financial result for the taxpayers.
What were the improvements they made?
So first off, they constructed and they maintain all the improvements out there in that sublease
area, what was referred to as the food village.
Their initial investment within that area was a little bit over $6 million.
They also, when we constructed the Orion, we actually did not do any of the finishes
in any of the concessions areas.
So if you've been out there to a concert and you've gone to any one of those concessions
areas, what you walk up to when we originally turned it over to HBG Food and Beverage, those
were just shelled out empty spaces.
They did all the furnishings, they did all the equipping, all the signage, everything
that it takes to make those work.
Those were all capital assets they invested in and they still own.
And those altogether were about three and a half million.
So at the outset, they invested about $9.5 million and they own those assets.
We actually got an appraisal as part of this process.
They're currently valued at a little bit over $8.8 million.
So that is the current assessed and appraised value of all the capital assets.
So that component of this proposed transaction, we are buying buildings, we are buying hard
infrastructure and we are buying equipment and supplies and things that they currently
own.
This gives you a little bit of, this was their plans.
If you've been out there, you know what they refer to here as the barn is what they've
now branded as Jeffin Blues.
Of course, a large pavilion and then a lot of infrastructure improvements that accommodate
all the food trucks and some of the event spaces and things.
It's outside of the amphitheater building itself.
And that's a satellite shot.
So you see what it looks like today.
And so in pictorial form, this transaction tonight would eliminate that as a separate
sublease area.
And all of that would become part of the amphitheater side and fully under our ownership and then
operations management of HVGA.
So what are the assets to purchase?
So as I've mentioned, the buildings, the improvements all throughout the food village area, all
the furnishings, equipment, improvements in the concessions area inside the amphitheater,
all on hand supplies, materials, service, utensils, equipment, every single thing it
takes for them to function there.
The intellectual property, so all of the branding and marketing materials and menus and all
those kinds of things.
And the net and buying out the contractual rights and the net present value 12 years
of anticipated and what they have in terms of contractual rights to revenues, net present
value is $10 million.
So what are we proposing in consideration for that and payment for that is a total of
$12 million in cash.
And then we do need to do some restructuring to the operating agreement.
Now, so let's line that up as I said, the capital asset is appraised at 8.8.
We have agreed to a price of 8 million, so about 10% below the appraised value of those
assets.
And then a contract buyout of 4 million against a net present value of 10 million.
And the operating agreement, this is important because how is this thing managed on our behalf?
How do we incentivize good financial decisions and what does this look like for our citizens
that continue to use it?
Start on the left-hand side, some of the important aspects of this agreement that do not change
from the existing agreement as it stands today.
There's no change to their terms.
They're currently in the first 10-year term, which expires in 2032.
There are some mutual rights to extension on the backside of that.
So if they're still performing and doing what we need them to do, they'll have the right
to extend this agreement beyond 2032, but that's a decision that will need to come back
before city council when we get a lot closer to 2032.
There's no change in their minimum performance metrics.
There are specific metrics in place of things that they have to do, and I'll talk here in
a little bit about how we're structuring the incentive package for them.
It is based on minimum performance standards, and if they don't meet those standards, they
don't get the payment.
There's no change to their programming obligations, no change to termination clauses or any of
the insurances and demifications and things, and no change to facility maintenance standards.
Most of the facility maintenance that occurs there is their responsibility.
There are some things that are held back that general services assist them with, but the
vast majority of the day-to-day maintenance and improvements are all managed by them.
And we do have a capital, a capex account that promoters and users of the facility have
to contribute to in order to help pay for those future improvements in maintenance and
things.
On the right-hand side are the things that are being adjusted in the operating agreement
from where it sits today to what is proposed to amend it to tonight.
So first off, in the existing agreement, why that concessions agreement could even exist
is in the prior agreement.
They had the right to do that.
Now we also, because of the development agreement and the way we're trying to encourage some
private development, needed them to do it.
But what we do here is prohibit them from ever contracting out food and beverage again.
It has to be retained internal.
And what's important about that is retained internal to the Orion operations managed by
HVGA on our behalf.
But what's really important is 100% of those revenues have to go onto our profit and loss
statement as opposed to going to a private company on the outside as it exists today.
There are a number of different categories of sponsorships in the venue.
Some are paid directly to the city.
Some are absorbed into the P&L of the operating budget there, specifically beverage company
sponsorships which currently go to HVG Food and Beverage will now come directly to the
city.
Right now where they say there's multiple different companies they have sponsorship
agreements with, that's about $200,000 a year that will now come directly to the city that
is not in the existing agreement.
We do as part of this increased scope for HVGA and as a component of working the buyout
of the contract, we are increasing their gross revenue share to HVGA.
So when we think about it in the existing agreement, there's really two ways in which
HVGA can earn money.
One is a share of gross revenues as just a base management fee.
And then there is a structured net profit share.
One of the challenges and I'll have some supplements to get a little bit more detail.
In the existing agreement, the way the net profit was structured, we now know in hindsight
it was essentially impossible for them to earn it.
And so the reason you want to line up an incentive around profitability is to incentivize behavior.
Incentivize maximizing revenues and minimizing expenses.
But if you make that incentive impossible to achieve, it doesn't necessarily affect
the behavior you're looking for.
So we're looking to restructure that in a way where they really do have an opportunity
to earn it.
If they really earn it is because they're doing extremely well and we're making more
money.
But ultimately you need to restructure that to make that actually function as an incentive
to them.
We do significantly increase our monthly and quarterly financial reporting requirements
off of the existing agreement.
And we also in the existing agreement, the capex that we set as the price that a promoter
has to contribute towards future to that, to the capex and to the maintenance account.
It had no escalators out in the future.
It did not contemplate inflation.
In conversation with them, we felt like there ought to be some step up in the future for
promoters to pay in order to contribute towards that.
So this does provide that in future years.
I think the first step up isn't until 2030.
There's a couple of step ups.
So they're in the out years to improve that contribution into the capital accounts.
So if you use that, I'm going to use FY25 actual numbers here to kind of estimate for
you how this money moves.
Because FY25, we think was a good year at the Orion.
We feel like as we look at the first four years and kind of what we see, we think it
is fairly representative of what we ought to see going forward.
So on the left is the way it's currently structured.
Under a 5% gross revenue share for their management fee, HVGA got just short of $200,000.
But the profit incentive was set up on net of the entire operation at the percentage
of breakdown you see there.
Well, the way that is structured and with food and beverage being outside of the revenue
stream for the Orion, there realistically was no way for them to ever earn that.
So they got zero off that profit incentive.
But HVGA FMB, the separate company, we did get as required by the lease payment, 7% of
the gross revenues, but ultimately the net income, so the profitability of the food and
beverage business was about $1.7 million.
Now that shouldn't be surprising.
When you look at any venue like this, the most profitable segment of the business is
going to be food and beverage with a lot of emphasis on beverage.
And you can kind of see that by the nature of events.
There's some events where there's going to be more alcohol consumption, there's going
to be some where there's very little and you can see the spin per head float up and down
across those concerts.
You can really see how food and beverage drives the revenue potential of a venue like this.
That's true at the VBC and other places where we have these kind of operations.
So in the aggregate, TBG, the corporate, between its two subsidiaries here functioning in and
around the Orion took out about a $1.9 million net income that they earned off the Orion.
Now when you look at our budgeting and you just look at this year's budget, FY26, we
have had to budget in the general fund about $2 million, using round figures, in order
to balance the budget at the Orion.
And that lines up very, very closely with what we're seeing go out and go to their corporate
headquarters off the food and beverage business.
And so this is really about pulling that back into the Orion.
And so what you see on the right is the way those same set of numbers, so using trying
to do an apples to apples comparison, again using FY25 actuals.
So had this new structure been in place for FY25, these are the estimates of what would
have happened there.
One is you see the increased gross revenue.
So they would have, their base management fee would have been about $700,000 and they
actually would have been able to earn some of that profit incentive and that would have
been about $300,000.
But the other piece of this new structure is they don't get that $1.7 million.
But I want to go back up to the top because when we see, hey, they're getting, they're
able to grow their share, 100% of their compensation is tied to performance.
If revenues go up, their share goes up, but so does ours.
So every dollar that revenue goes up, they get $0.08, we get $0.92.
And so we are just at the top line and up to the top line is not all the way it's at.
That's just the beginning of a profit loss statement.
But right off the bat in their base management agreement, we are incentivizing them to maximize
revenues which can then flow down through the profit loss statement.
But we also want to make sure that they are focused on the actual net profitability in
any segment of the business that is actually expected to be profitable and that's in those
big concerts.
And so what you'll see in future profit loss statements, one is breaking out so we see
clear overhead of expenses so we understand the expenses that it takes regardless of what's
going on at a day at the Orion, but then see the actual profit loss in the net off of the
concert segment as compared to all those free events that we're doing that are the community
events.
And what this allows us to do is when you earn that profit off of the concert business,
that money can then be used to fund those free events.
And we believe strongly in continuing to maintain and hopefully grow more and more of that broad,
very inexpensive or even free where appropriate access to events in the Orion.
So that's what really this is about.
So when you compare in the aggregate, so some folks say, okay, how much is TVG up in New
York City making off of this under today's structure in FY 25 about 1.9 million under
the new structure, it would have been about 1 million.
And the rest of that money is staying right here in Huntsville and structured in a way
that we believe better incentivizes the very financial and budget discipline that we all
need to have, but particularly in a place like this to drive that profitability.
So I've had some folks, let me just hit y'all with some questions I've received.
And then I certainly want to hear your questions.
I've had folks say, okay, we're investing $12 million.
What's the payback on that?
How do we get our money back?
And I would say, first off, we need to think and understand where that money goes and for
what purpose.
The first portion of that, that $8 million, you're buying a real asset.
And at the end of five years, 10 years, 15 years, 20 years, you still own those buildings,
you still own those improvements like you do other city facilities.
And so that asset will continue to retain value.
And so trying to compare, okay, how much of that $8 million do I still have?
Obviously, we could get appraisals every so often and put a number to it, but it's not
dissimilar to other capital investments we make in terms of building buildings and making
improvements and stuff.
We own those assets where right now today we don't.
So we're buying real assets.
I had somebody say, hey, you're just giving them a gift.
No, we're, you know, starting with the $8 million piece.
We are buying real things that have been inventoried and appraised and we have a real appraised
value on them today.
And the price we're getting is a little bit below that appraised value.
Then the other piece is the operations.
And we are essentially buying an operating successful business.
Now if one of us wanted to go buy, you know, a high performing restaurant downtown and
you're just taking over the business as it exists and you're getting all of the menus
and all of the staff and all the equipment and the building and everything, certainly
there'd be a value to the building and the tables and the chairs and things, but there
would also be value to those future potential revenue streams.
But in that example, you've actually got to go do work and earn those things.
And there's obviously work to be done here.
But what HPG Food and Beverage has is a contractual right to those revenues.
And so if somebody asks, well, why don't you just cancel the contract and kick them out?
Well, they have a legal right.
You know, we and the appropriate authorities approved and signed that contract.
And so, you know, if we just said, hey, get out of here, we're taking over, they'd say,
well, we'll see you in court.
And they would win that case because they have real contractual rights.
And we need to honor those legal obligations that we collectively entered into.
So the net present value of those reasonably modeled future revenues is about $10 million.
And we have been in negotiations for a while.
As you can imagine, they started at a bigger number than what we ultimately agreed to.
So what we have agreed to is the $4 million upfront plus for HVGA some improved revenue
streams, but HVGF and B, it goes to zero.
And so you see how those numbers behave.
But when you look at that, you know, that contract component of it, you know, for improving
our overall profitability there by that $1.5 to $2 million range, I'm just going to fluctuate
year to year as the concert business goes.
And over time with inflation, that number gets bigger.
But you're really the $4 million, you're getting back in about two and a half to three years.
And then you continue to improve the impact on the general fund.
What do I think happens this year?
Because obviously we're making a decision midseason.
You know, as I said, in FY26, we need to budget about $2 million in order to balance the budget.
I think we see that number get substantially better because of this.
So you know, it's not going to have a full year impact on FY26 because a chunk of the
season is already gone.
But we do see immediate impact in this fiscal year to improve that number.
And then you see the full year impact starting really on one October, so we can get you a
full year number.
So, you know, I don't want to say that here halfway through the year, we're going to have
that full $1.7 to $2 million impact because we're like say we're halfway through the year.
But we definitely see an appreciable improvement.
And then you go into the full year impact starting on one October and beyond.
So that's, you know, those are the assets that were proposed to buy and how we see it
impacting the financials.
And I do want to emphasize that budget number is a direct impact to the general fund.
So at this point, I think open up to questions.
Mr. members, we have questions.
Mr. Little and Ms. Watkins.
Just real quick.
Original projections to pay down the debt when this was started was about 20 years?
Yes.
From day one of Orion's, I went around back then.
And then there were no new debt for this deal.
Correct.
So first off, you know, so what is the debt?
No, no, this is a project because of the nature of the way we wanted to design and build it
as well as the way we wanted to manage the debt on it.
This was turned over to for the public building authority to execute on our behalf.
People ask me, okay, what other projects that PBA done?
The PBA built the jail quite a few years ago, and they built this building, they built the
Orion.
And there are some other projects, I think, in the out years that we'll evaluate may make
sense to have the PBA do them in or may not.
And those are decisions this council would make if we come to those.
So in this case, the PBA bought the money, the debt load on this was a combination of
debt and cash.
But the debt piece was about 37 million.
And this does not add to that.
It is a 20 year that's the way we do all of our debt.
Generally speaking, there's an occasional exception, but generally we do 20 year debt.
That's what this was.
So our lease payment, the city's lease payment to the PBA is, you know, each year is the
amount of their debt service.
And that's essentially the way the process works out.
You're right.
We're not here for that, you know, as part of the council's approval for them to move
forward, they approve a lease that says we'll pay you whatever your debt service is, they
now have a guarantee that they can actually pay back the debt.
And that's what they use to go to the market and borrow the money against that against
that guaranteed lease payment.
And so each year we make that debt service payment as a lease payment to the PBA and
then they pay the debt.
But it is a 20 year payback.
We are not proposing to use any debt in this transaction.
This is this is money available in the capital plan is cash right now.
Other questions.
Ms. Watkins.
Yes.
Thank you for that presentation, Mr. Hamilton.
I just have a couple of questions.
Is the 12 million is going to be payable in one lump sum or over time?
So it the simple answer to your question is yes, it's paid at closing.
But if you really dig into the agreement, there's actually some some pieces that we
hold back in escrow to ensure that there's not any unexpected things as we continue through
the transition.
So initially, they would get 11 and a half million, we hold back 500 K. And then we also
if if if as we went through it, if we found an error in the inventory or found some issue
that that was their obligation to pay, we could pull it out of that 500 K. And if it
exceeded that, then we could actually hold back their management fees going forward.
So we are covered in terms of if there's if there's some issue found post closing.
What part of money will this 12 million come from?
Will it be the general fund?
No, it's from the capital plan capital.
And we felt that was most of one of the things that happened here.
And this is also, you know, as we talked through today, you know, I was really reflecting on
the fact that, you know, we had a different city council that originally did this, you
know, you weren't your seat and Mr. Little was not here either.
And I think some of this actually started before Mr. Meredith came on council.
And then he got here in time for some of the decisions.
So he kind of came in mid stride.
And so this the original proposal while while for years, we've had citizens talking about
wanting an empathy or this kind of thing in our community.
And I think, you know, the city was really holding off for a while just kind of looking
for the right opportunity.
This was really done as part of the catalyst and the injection of city infrastructure into
the mid city to get get that dead mall, that whole thing really ramped up.
And we're obviously seeing the payback through mid city and that I think will continue as
it continues to develop that for the next few years.
I say all of that to say, because of that, this was done really as an economic development
project.
And so the 2014 plan where where we have money set aside for economic development is really
what has done the capital investment here.
And this is an extension of that capital investment that we've got with the most most consistent
and appropriate way to line up this investment.
Do you have an ROI on the buyout?
So I was trying to get at that with with the way I kind of describe what that what that
payback is.
You know, I try to do the quick math in my head, which may be dangerous in public.
But you know, what we see in terms of the return back to net profitability relative
to the contract buyout, there's really about two and a half years.
If you want to go to the full 12 million, you're about seven and a half years that that,
you know, annual improvement to the bottom line gets you past the 12 million dollar mark.
Now, some folks would say it's not completely fair because you still own an asset at the
end of that.
12 million is still an asset that you own, so you probably wouldn't, you know, if you're
really doing that.
But you know, if you really want to fully pay back your 12 million out of that improved
profitability, it's about seven and a half year mark.
And then from then on, it's it's pure contribution to the bottom line.
Now what this does from our own city budget, because we've got all these different funds.
And so y'all, you know, every September, you've got to make decisions on how you're balancing
different funds against each other.
What we've seen, you know, obviously, there's a lot of conversation last September, and
I think we'll have it again this September is challenges in the general fund and things
that we need to do in terms of improving other services and how we make sure we take our
employees and all the things that come out of the general fund.
A lot of the stuff that we've been working on internally and bringing to y'all when when
it's appropriate is things that really help bolster the general fund.
And this is an example of that.
This is a direct contribution back into the general fund.
And so, you know, as we're looking at how we bring you a good balanced general fund
budget in September, this will absolutely make a difference in that.
One second, I'm making notes.
Sorry.
Has an audit been conducted?
I see you got detailed information about, you know, the assets that the company has
and agreements in, but has an audit been conducted?
So we have not done one.
We're obligated to to do their audits.
Some of their some of their requirements as a for profit company, you know, under SEC
rules and under under IRS rules a little bit different than ours.
And so the kind of audit that, you know, Ms. Smith and I would be looking for the way we
audit our books.
That's not the way the way those kind of companies do that.
Part of what I talk about, we have significantly increased some of the reporting requirements
in the new operating agreement gets us closer to that and we'll obligate them to do that.
And I think we we we always have the rights to come in and inspect their books.
And we've done that some.
We've got to do more of that and we will start getting more detailed reports through this
process.
I've gone back and gotten a lot of historical records and a lot of the the numbers that
we use in this negotiation tied directly to literally show by show performance of how
things are going and verifying, you know, exactly how how these numbers flow.
Those who are comfortable with the numbers.
But one of the things that we've got to do and why we specifically wanted to add those
aspects to this agreement was to strengthen those even more than they already are.
Is it possible to get a third party review prior to the buyout?
Third party audit review.
That would probably be measured in months.
It would if you want to do that prior to approving this agreement, then we would just need to
set this aside, go do that and then negotiate because by that time you're changing much
of the financials around things as time goes forward.
And so doing doing one prior to to the contract approval, we would basically just start over
again to some extent.
And I definitely don't want to be difficult.
But when you talk about spending 12 million dollars of taxpayer money, then you know,
it's just questions that have to be asked and make sure that we're not leaving any
eyes not dotted and T's not crossed.
So one last question I have.
Will you have a detailed transition that sustainability plan?
Yes.
And part of the advantage of way this is working, you know, I think I said this to Mr. Merritt,
we were talking about, you know, the the patron experience out there.
And I think it's kind of a good way to think about what's happening here.
You know, if you went to a concert a week ago and then you go to a concert, you know,
like this is approved tonight and you go to a concert a week from now, you absolutely
won't tell any difference because it's the same people operating it.
It's under it's under our managers leadership as opposed to the private company.
But if you've got your favorite concession worker, he or she is still going to be there.
It's all it's all the same people, the same menus, the same food.
We're literally buying the supplies they have in the store rooms right now.
So operationally, that's invisible to the outside.
Where you'll see the difference is if you pay attention to the budget conversation
in September and seeing the changes in the way in which the financials work, that's really
where you see the difference.
And so the actual transition of operations is will be seamless.
And that's that's easy to do.
What what's important to us is the piece going forward of exactly how we are coming in and
scrutinizing those numbers, doing those increased reporting requirements and ultimately the
audits when we get to the end of the year and reviewing those things.
I said I had that was my last question, but I missed my very first question.
I thought it was a note, but it's a question.
When FB and HVGA approached the city about purchasing and acquiring their assets, did
they give you a reason why they want to get out of this contract?
They did.
Now, you know, it was an arms league negotiation.
And so they may have some things internal that that that they're not as a private company
prepared to to disclose.
But there's a couple of different things that they talk with us about it.
One is while that component of the business has gone well, the reality is this this company
is largely building its reputation around the Orion.
We partner very closely with them in the concept and the development.
There's a lot of things.
I mean, you know, when I talk about we wanted to model after the St. Augustine amphitheater,
which is also a public asset.
It's actually owned by St. John's County down in Florida.
What they were doing there was so unique in the things outside of the concert business
that we went and hired away the manager.
And so many of you all have met Ryan Murphy, who works for that company.
He was the manager for the county down there in Florida and has come here and implemented
the very things that we saw.
And in fact, Mr. Davis and I went down and visited down there and went to a concert and
went to a farmer's market and saw the way they were using the property.
And so that really was kind of part of our due diligence and figuring out how we wanted
to do this.
But ultimately bringing bringing that in.
Really, you know, this is less about the original concept for the Orion and more about the attempt
to spur some private development that has not turned out financially that we want to
do.
And, you know, buying that out and doing something that we think is more beneficial to the taxpayers
long term is really kind of getting out of that private stuff and making it all public
and owned by the taxpayers as opposed to private development that's there.
So I think part of it is I think they genuinely want to see the Orion do better.
And so that's a piece of it.
They also have a number of things they're doing around the country and even overseas.
They actually are involved in some venues over in England, but they have they have venues
now in New York to work on some in Texas, a number in California and things like that.
And so some of this is just where where is it best for them to place their capital.
And so they think this is the right time to pull that capital out.
Now, quite frankly, as I mentioned, we negotiated they're not they're not getting as much money
as I asked for.
I think, you know, between, you know, Mr. Davis and I together, you know, with some
fairly tough negotiations and we, you know, we wanted to go fight for getting the best
deal for the taxpayers.
But ultimately, they I think they're in a position where it's better for them.
One, some of that they've actually borrowed some money.
So some of that private development, they have some debt that they use to fund it along
with along with equity.
And so I think it's beneficial and financially to get that debt off their books and then
redeploy that capital into some other things.
I will tell you, they you know, there's been some stuff out in the public about another
smaller private venue in the mid-city area and they are directly involved in that.
My expectation is that if that if their deal is able to go forward and they're doing that
with some other partners, both local and and from elsewhere in the U.S. come in to to partner
on a purely private deal.
My expectation is some of this money rolls back into that investment that stays right
there in mid-city.
So some of that money stays right here in our community.
Ultimately, obviously, we're buying an asset from them.
So it's their money.
But where they deploy it is a lot of what you all do in economic development, right,
is encouraging folks to deploy their private dollars into our community.
So I think some of it comes back.
So I think it's it's probably a combination of things.
I think the relationships that we've built with them, they do have there's there's you
know, there's a shared experience here with the Iran and they want it to do well.
But ultimately, you know, they're in the business of making money.
I mean, they're not you know, they're not here to be charitable.
But you know, they just want to redeploy their capital elsewhere.
Well, let me say I absolutely I think you won for earlier today when you gave me a call
and explained things to me.
But I absolutely do respect you and Shane and what you do and what you say.
You're very knowledgeable.
And I appreciate you answering these questions.
But I still just have heartburn with this $12 million.
And I don't know if it's possible council members, but I'd like to table it to the next
meeting.
I need time to think about this.
And I'm just asking until the next meeting to give me an opportunity just to go back
through the paperwork and absorb this and really think about this decision.
As Watkins has made a motion to table.
Is there a second?
Hearing no second the motion.
It does.
Okay.
Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
Any other questions?
No.
Thank you, Mr. Hamilton.
I have one one other question for you.
You mentioned the $2 million subsidy that we provide every year, which basically, as
I understand it, pays for all of those 200 something community events.
So how does this purchase impact that subsidy and how and will we still continue to fund
community events?
We will.
But and so in here's really kind of just as we think about how you know, the the money
kind of flows down the profit and loss statement from top to bottom.
All right.
So how kind of just hopefully kind of give a give a mental picture.
You know, at the top, you'll see the the overhead expenses oftentimes referred to as SG&A.
There's a little bit of revenue that's kind of that is facility wide that is not tied
to individual events.
And that's you know, but but a lot of expenses.
The salaries, the full time employees is overhead.
And so there's an overhead expense that needs to be shared by those other by those other
the actual events.
And then kind of the next section down, you would see expenses and revenues tied specifically
to the major concerts and the private hires.
So those events that are at market value, they're exclusive ticketed type events.
Those are the ones where they would anticipate those those events, certainly try every individual
event to be profitable on its own.
But really, in the aggregate, you expect that and it has historically been profitable becomes
much more profitable when you add in the food and beverage operations that as opposed to
keeping it segregated.
And so you get down to to a net income at the bottom of that.
Now, one of the things that we're requiring them to do because their profit incentive
is tied specifically to that category, that category has to carry 70% of the load from
the SG&A.
Okay.
And so, you know, you've gone through your typical revenues, and you go through your
typical expenses add in 70% of the overhead.
And that net income at the end is what their profit incentive is tied to.
And what that really does mathematically is incentivize them not to not only to be very
efficient in the direct expenses inside of an event, it also incentivizes them to be
more efficient in the overhead as well.
Because that ties directly to their bottom line and ours.
And again, if they've earned a great big incentive is because we've earned an even bigger profit.
So we want them to do that we'd love for them to get that huge incentive fee because then
we've we've made a lot of money.
And what I mean we the taxpayers, you know.
So then that net income that net profit at the bottom is then available to assist with
the expenses and then the next category down which is all those community and cultural
events.
Well, there are some revenues off of those, they don't come remotely close to covering
all the expenses and those things I mean we are doing a lot of events out there, where
we are either letting letting an event organizer use the facility completely for free there's
no rental charge whatsoever and people can come in and enjoy a thing for free.
Sometimes it might be a small rental fee but well below you know the cost that it has to
open up and turn on the lights and everything of the venue.
But again, that's much like an extension of our rec centers right it's an extension of
our parks and rec program.
And so when you look at just that category you get to the bottom line is a negative number.
And so certainly the goal here is and what we're pushing them to do is that positive
number that was the bottom line off your concerts is the same or more than the negative number
at the bottom of community events.
And so you're getting to a balanced budget.
And that's and that's the goal.
Certainly you know as we as we see you know things go they may not quite get there but
if we are having to send a subsidy becomes a much smaller number.
But there's another piece to this.
There are a couple categories of sponsorships.
So specifically I mentioned earlier specifically the beverage company sponsorship is a change
is that's why I highlighted it.
The thing that's staying the same there's a category of foundational sponsors and so
you see four major sponsors that are out there.
So Ford Bank Independent.
Axis which is the ticketing system.
And the fourth one's escape from mine right now there's four foundational sponsors that
each have annual agreements.
A hundred percent of those revenues minus the expense that it takes to market them.
But so probably about ninety five percent of those revenues come directly to the city.
So those are things that they don't get to earn a gross revenue incentive off of nor
does it tie into the profitability.
That's money comes directly to us.
And so the first place that we go to balance the budget is those revenues that are coming
directly to us of those sponsorships.
That's a piece that sometimes gets forgotten.
And so right now as we look at the kind of historical numbers and the way we expect it
to behave with this additional revenue in there I do expect those sponsorships to be
able to cover any additional loss that may still exist in the aggregate between the concert
category and the community event category.
And the bottom line of all of that is it will lessen the impact on the general fund.
Exactly.
Thank you.
And certainly the goal is the goal is to get it to where this general fund is sending zero
dollars out there to assist with the Orion.
Now where I was going with it.
And I will tell you you know the there's we have a lot of within the city lots in different
forms venues that the city owns that we have you know board or whoever operating for us
that are really quality lot kind of things the BBC the Iceplex the tennis center the
various museums are all examples of that.
We only have right now one of those where we do not have to send money to balance the
operating budget.
That's the ice.
And all the others in order to keep pricing at a reasonable level or to even keep some
of those things for free for our community our our city budget through one form or another
some cases lodging taxes or even liquor taxes or which are part of the general fund go to
help balance those those budgets.
So if we can get to the Orion to where it's paying for itself and it balances to zero
then it will be our second venue that's doing that.
That's not a criticism of those other venues.
The only way for some of those things in the reason government is involved in some of those
kinds of quality of life investments for our community the only way they can keep pricing
reasonable is to understand they got to have a subsidy to help with their operations.
If if you told all of them they had to balance to zero the pricing would go through the roof
and that's why you don't see private industry delivering some of those kind of public services
that that we do in the recreational world.
Thank you.
Any other questions.
All in favor please indicate.
Any opposed.
Let the record show that Ms Watkins has voted in the negative and the motion passes with
a majority of four.
We will move on to 20 20 is a resolution authorizing the mayor to extend a gift offer to U.S. Army
Garrison Redstone Arsenal for U.S. Space Command senior leader housing and infrastructure improvements
is there a motion.
Motion from Mr. Little second for Mr. Klein question.
Yes sir.
I know you've got the terminology gifting or whatever.
Is this going to the general or whomever is living in the domicile or is this money going
to the federal government.
Can we let Mr. Davis do the presentation and then we'll come back.
Absolutely.
So good evening council members again Shane Davis director urban economic development.
So what is before you is a resolution that starts to put in motion an incentive local
incentive that was put in place almost seven years ago.
There's been a lot of fanfare with Space Command and where its permanent home would
be to RFPs or RFIs and national politics that we stayed out of but that end of the day U.S.
Space Command is coming on by Obama recent rendering.
So that was a national competition all 50 states in any community within those states
got to submit an RP initially then they come back out with a second with the top five.
We were one of those top five.
So it was a competitive process.
It's no different.
I would put it in perspective of Mazda Toyota Toyota engine plant.
It's been North Huntsville for 20 years recently Eli Lilly.
I would say you know all those are great companies are public trading are doing well here in
Huntsville and across the globe right.
What I will say is is U.S.
Space Command is much like NASA and the FBI and the other agents from Teenage Stone Redstone
and research part.
It provides stability in our overall GDP.
It's not guaranteed.
We've got federal contracts that have to be voted on and budgets and continue to resolutions
whatever is happening in the C. But historically if you look the last 50 years in Huntsville
it has been the lifeblood of North Alabama's economy and our growth is 2 to 3 percent.
That's no reason for you to vote for this tonight.
Okay.
But we understood what our DNA was seven years ago.
We understood this was no different of a competition than we do every day.
I had a mega industry projects been here for two days and and we're in a competitive nature
of that and we'll see where we go.
I can tell you in this community the mayor has a quote says we'll never go by project.
We know our DNA.
We know what a job is worth.
We know what it's worth to to try to secure that whether it's a federal agency such as
Space Command or it's a you know a publicly traded or non-public entity that we brought
into Huntsville.
So in that proposal we partnered with the state of Alabama and part of that was to provide
three things for primarily at the time first it was to provide general officer quarters.
We've done that in two different occasions on two rounds of BRAC.
We are not giving any cash to the federal government or Redstone Arsenal.
So on behalf of the state what happens is they partner with our BRAC committee our local
BRAC committee that's been in place or for many years and they'll work with a garrison's
office the Department of Public Works on the arsenal and they'll help deploy to get those
houses built.
So they're at the state of Alabama their $15 million is actually gifting a finished home
on federal property and they've done that on two different occasions around the BRAC.
What currently is being proposed would be 12 general officer housing new housing on
Redstone but the state will manage that.
In this gift letter you see $30 million for the city of Huntsville.
That's more than just this body.
So that's Huntsville utilities and our utility partners so many of you are aware that Huntsville
utilities entered into an IGSA, Intergovernmental Services Agreement for Redstone where they
help provide management of their natural gas, their electric, their water, they're essentially
the utility company of Redstone.
Certainly this is a greenfield site from Redstone Arsenal which needs utilities brought to it
just as the FBI needed utilities brought to it and as things grow on the arsenal and
expand.
So Huntsville utilities they do outside the gate in our community when we have a Eli Lilly
or something in Research Park they go deliver those utilities to that property line.
So in that about $10 million of the 30 is part of that just normal course of business.
Certainly there's a utility charge that power and water and gas is not free so just like
any other industry Huntsville utilities you've got a revenue stream coming back to that capital
investment.
The remaining 20 is up to $20 million to support bringing other infrastructure so we run sewer.
So we'll be providing the sewer at Huntsville utilities not in that business so a portion
of it will be for additional utilities and helping guarantee fiber and internet services
to this greenfield site on post and then we will be preparing site work.
So doing some clearing and grading and actual grade work.
Some of that may be us actually bringing you a bid that you would have to vote on.
So we have a set of plans and we go bid, get a low bidder and we come to you at a later
date and ask you to approve that expenditure.
Some of it may be in kind where we use water pollution control or public works and we're
providing in kind.
There's no actual exchange of cash but we get a value for that.
We get to place a value on that in kind service, that donated service there and we don't know
what that will look like but as we move forward we'll be bringing that to this body.
So tonight what you're voting on is just for us to officially deliver this gift letter
as our proposal said seven years ago and then we'll move forward as we deploy these gifts
if you will.
For us it's going to be utilities and some in kind site work.
Should we bid any of that work it would follow the public works bid law that we would bring
to you and you would have to approve that actual effort, that contract.
I'll answer any questions now you may have.
What questions do we have now Mr. Klink?
Okay I think there's just some information out there that you could clarify who will
actually own the houses once they're constructed.
So the U.S. Army will own those and remember those housing, the funds for those housing
will come from the state of Alabama.
That is their gift.
I think there's a conception out there from some people that we're actually buying a house
for an Army general here and there.
That's incorrect.
Thank you.
Other questions?
Anybody else?
Then we'll proceed.
I have a comment.
When the vote comes up I would be recusing myself.
Thank you for making that.
Because ethically I work for the garrison and I don't want any ethics concerns brought
up.
I respect that and knew you were in a tough position due to your day job.
Thank you for making a note of that and the record will reflect that.
Any other comments?
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Nay.
Let the record show that the motion carries by majority vote.
Mr. Meredith has voted in the negative and Ms. Watkins has recused.
The motion carries.
Thank you councilmembers.
We will go on to 20G.
Madam President, if you don't mind, we have a guest here tonight and usually when we have
guests we bump them up on the agenda.
The House of Housing Authority director Mr. McGinnis is here and he's been waiting patiently
for that presentation.
Can we move that up?
Councilmembers that's item 20A, it would actually be the last item for consideration tonight.
Would you have an objection to moving up?
No objection but if you could state it in terms of suspending the rules since we have
already approved the agenda, if we could suspend the rules to move him up.
I request that we suspend, I motion that we suspend the rules to move up item 20A for
the guest Mr. McGinnis to be able to hear the presentation without him having to stay
for the interview.
And I'll second that motion.
Second.
All in favor please indicate.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
We then take item 20A out of order.
20A is a resolution authorizing the Mayor to enter into an agreement between the City
of Huntsville and EJP Consulting Group LLC for professional services in developing the
Phase 1 portfolio assessment for the Huntsville Housing Authority.
Is there a motion to approve?
Chair makes the motion.
Second.
Second from Ms. Watkins.
Good evening.
I hate to disappoint you.
We don't actually have a presentation and we're just going to talk over the item.
Dennis Madsen with Huntsville City Planning.
So this item is really kind of a joint planning effort and it's something that the Housing
Authority and the Planning Department have talked about for a while due to growth pressures
within the city and recognizing that we need to be proactive about ensuring that there
continues to be affordability throughout the city.
We found that kind of an analysis of what you would call a portfolio analysis of all
the housing properties, looking at that and thinking in terms of, you know, what makes
sense, what would need kind of near-term attention, what can be delayed a little bit longer.
And that becomes a tool for Mr. McGinnis and his team.
But it also helps the city in some of our planning.
As I think many of you recognize, we have several projects that immediately have bought
some of the Housing Authority properties.
We have Holmes Avenue, which hits two Housing Authority properties.
We have the North Huntsville Greenway, which also runs past two Housing Authority properties.
So at its core, this is an opportunity for us to coordinate planning between what the
city is doing and what the Housing Authority is doing.
And Mr. McGinnis was kind enough to join us tonight in case there were questions also
for the Housing Authority.
Thank you, Mr. Madsen.
Are there any questions for Mr. McGinnis or Mr. Madsen?
Ms. Watkins.
So exactly, would the study evaluate all of the public housing units?
Yes, ma'am.
Every single property in their portfolio excluding Mill Creek, since that is currently under
active redevelopment.
And you say the purpose of this is to evaluate the conditions of the property?
There will be physical needs assessments as part of that, as well as examination of potential
financing mechanisms should they need assistance.
I don't think it's any secret that the stream of funds flowing to Housing Authorities really
around the country have been slowing down to closer to a trickle over time.
So Housing Authorities are having to be more creative about not just redeveloping but maintaining
their properties.
This is a chance to kind of look at a kind of broad portfolio of strategies that they
can utilize over time to make sure that they're taking care of their properties.
Do you have an estimate from the company that's going to do the evaluation of how long this
will take?
The assessment will take between 5 and 6 months.
They will.
They do have a site visit and will be scheduling interviews with some of the folks who are
associated with the Housing Authority and other interested parties.
But this is really just kind of the first phase.
It gives sort of a roadmap for the future after which we can start making decisions
in conjunction obviously with the Housing Authority about what properties get what attention.
Yes.
And I'm pretty sure with you standing here presenting this that the Board at the House
for Housing Authority is in agreement with this as well.
Yes, ma'am.
And we actually have a Board member of the Housing Authority with us too.
Yes.
Okay.
And for the sake of the public, because by the time we leave here, it will be twisted
that we're doing this so we can immediately shut down public housing.
I just want to clear up.
I completely understand.
Yes.
This is really just looking at the portfolio at HUD and the Housing Authority have very
strict regulations on moving any sort of development forward.
I mean, someone else commented earlier about it seems like Mill Creek is taking a lot of
time.
It's moving, but you have to be very deliberate.
You have to check all the boxes.
You have to do all your due diligence.
So nothing moves quickly after this assessment.
Okay.
And there after you get this assessment back, it'll go to House for Housing Authority, I'm
sure come to the city.
Will there be a presentation brought here to the council?
We'd be happy to do that.
Absolutely.
I would love for that presentation to be brought to the council.
And just respectfully, Mr. McGinnis, if he has any comments or anything he wants to say.
Mr. McGinnis, would you like to make any comments?
He might just be thinking of dinner like a lot of the rest of us.
He said that you do.
Out of courtesy.
And I thank you, Mr. McGinnis, for sitting patiently.
It was not oversight.
I just happened to look over and saw you sitting there.
So thank you, Mr. Madsen.
Do we have any other questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
The motion carries.
Mr. McGinnis, again, thank you for joining us.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Mr. Madsen.
All right.
We will resume the agenda.
I believe we're back on G. 20G is a resolution authorized by the mayor to enter into a agreement
between the City of Huntsville and Ferguson Group LLC for grant writing services for fiscal
year 2026 Defense Community Infrastructure Program.
Is there a motion to approve?
Second.
Motion for Mr. Little, second for Mr. Meredith.
Are there any questions anybody has about this?
I do.
Ms. Watkins.
Who's presenting?
Is anyone?
Oh.
Apologies.
That's okay.
Mr. Davis.
Yes, ma'am.
I just need to know, it says grant writing services for FY 2026 Defense Community Infrastructure
Program.
Yes, ma'am.
Exactly what is this?
So annually, this is a grant program that's open nationwide.
We have applied for these in the past, and it's very restrictive to communities who have
Federal military bases within their community.
So the competitive nature of this is think of public infrastructure that helps serve
the boundaries of, for us, it would be Redstone Arsenal.
So we've looked at things like Research Park Boulevard in the past, I-565.
So what we want to do is apply for a grant that's actually the number one priority of
Redstone Arsenal and the Gateway, which is Resolute Way, the new interchange, and apply
for partial construction funds.
That project is headed to construction here in a couple of years.
So we're just putting that forward.
We think it will compete very well.
One, it's a new access to Redstone Arsenal, but also helps alleviate traffic on Slaughter
Road.
It takes some traffic off the main gate coming into the Arsenal Research Park Boulevard.
So it helps our community also.
Is it primarily the traffic or would it also help with Resolute Way and Gateway?
Both.
The Gateway, yes, ma'am.
So it helps both.
Okay.
So one second.
Ms. Attorney Riley, do I need to recuse myself again?
Because it'll be Garrison again, will it not?
The grant will be funded through it.
Yes.
So all you would be voting on tonight is for, allows to hire this firm to help us submit
a grant.
If we were to receive the grant, I would think now we are providing benefit to Redstone.
I'll advise to our attorney, but that may be a situation that you would want to recuse.
But there is a difference in the way you presented.
So yes.
I think you're in good shape.
That's why I had you come up.
I wasn't sure about it.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20 aye.
20 aye as a resolution to authorize the mayor to enter an agreement between the City of
Huntsville and To The Point Inc. for engineering design services for Jackson Bend Connector
near Hazeland Road, project number 71-26-SP38.
Chairman is for approval.
Second.
Second from Mr. Meredith.
This is a long-awaited project in the particular Hayes Farm area that will create a number
of benefits.
So excited to see this move forward.
Yes, ma'am.
So again, this is a design and engineering contract with To The Point.
The actual contract amount is $134,984.
Includes surveying, geotechnical, and deliver construction specifications and plans to build
the road.
These well-established neighborhoods have in the master plan this morning to have connectivity
to the Hazeland Road extension.
It provides a little quicker access to Redstone than coming out of the neighborhoods, going
on to the parkway, and really trying to get back into Hobbs Road.
There's actually two connections.
One, Edinburgh is still going through some permitting process.
We think that will get ready to possibly be towards construction.
It says 26.
I'm thinking it probably rolls into early next year with some core permitting.
But the Jackson Bend Connector, we think, can go very quickly.
Tonight we're asking you to approve the design contract for us to quickly get plans, get
that project bid, and come back to council to award a construction contract.
Thank you.
Anybody have questions about this?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Motion carries.
Thank you very much.
This was just a good news project that I wanted to get out there.
20J is a resolution authorized in the Mayord-Antwerp Agreement between the City of Huntsville
and Three Notch Group, Inc., for engineering design services for Bailey Cove Multi-Use
Path between Weatherly Road and Four Maw Post, project number 71-26-SP40 and ALDOC, project
number TAPHVTA26940.
Chairman, it's for approval.
Second.
Second for Mr. Merritt.
Thank you, Madam President.
Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
So this project is projects we love to do, especially with our greenways, is be able
to use State and Federal funds and to be able to use the funds that we have.
So we're going to be able to use the funds that we have to be able to use the funds that
we have to be able to use the funds that we have to be able to use the funds that we
have to be able to use the funds that we have to be able to use the funds that we have
to be able to use the funds that we have to be able to use the funds that we have to be
able to use the funds that we have to be able to use the funds that we have to be able to
very similar in that 80-20 match. The general project scope here is a little over three miles
of new multi-purpose path that would connect there at Jones Family Park that's been well established
now for almost 20 years on Four Mile Post, tie into the existing Aldridge Creek Greenway, excuse me,
there on Four Mile Post Road, travel east on Four Mile Post, and then as you see in the red dash line
do south along Bailey Cove and tie back into an existing multi-use path to tie back into Aldridge
Creek Greenway. So you can really start to see this network really starting to get built out.
And then in the magenta or pink lines you start seeing the what I call the natural trail system
that exists and how we're connecting into those. And we're starting to see this get deployed in
other places especially in north the belt line stuff we're seeing in and around the airport as
we're continuing to expand some both paved multi-use paths and some natural trails and getting those
connected such that you know we can get more mileage out into our multi-use paths. Any questions?
So I would also point out the Sandor Moon Complex is right in the middle of it so it's providing
access to Sandor Moon and that's really important. So this little intersection improvement,
is that going to be at Blevins Gap? So there's two, one near Blevins Gap and the other one is
the, I should have showed both of them, the other one is there just at the Sandor Moon Complex.
You see kind of the round kind of highlighted dot circle there and what that really is is at that
intersection we expect a lot of activity on the greenway from north and south that want to cross
Bailey Cove, go into the Sandor Moon Complex and all of those amenities. So we want to make
intersection improvements to make sure the pedestrians either on bike or foot can can traverse
that very effectively and safely. That's a five lane you know major arterial in our city. So we've
just completed the big 15 mile loop down with the Hayes trails and Aldridge Creek and the River
Trail and this now adds to it and this is going to create an amazing greenway system. Thank you for
your work on it. There's existing sidewalks along this path now right? Some in spots you know they're
the old four foot which was the city standard used to be. We actually standard used to be three foot
and then went to four. We're now at five so we'll be replacing some of that. There's places where
there's gaps that will be brand new 10 foot wide multi-use path. Okay yeah but the whole red part
will be the new 10 foot. That's right. Okay gotcha. Cool thank you. Mr. Mayor. And my question is what is
the surface going to be? So as they get into design most likely it will be concrete. There may be
depending on soil conditions there may be asphalt but we predominantly especially along back of
curb and right away and knowing there's traveling motors beside concrete would probably be the most
more effective just from you know line of sight of recognizing the two different pavement types
especially as we're parallel in traffic. Thank you very much. Any other questions? All in favor please
indicate aye. Motion carries. Thank you all. 20 am y'all keep me straight I think 20 m is the next one.
20m is the resolution authorizing mayor to enter into a reimbursable agreement between the city of
Huntsville Alabama and Madison County Alabama for relocation of utility facilities on private
or public right of way for Winchester Road water relocation project project number 71-26-SP18
and project number ACAA 61222 A trip. Motion to approve. Motion for Mr. Little. Second from Mr. Merida.
Mr. Davis. Yes ma'am so these we bring you routinely especially federal aid construction
projects so this one is in relation to the last piece of widening of Winchester Road from ODB
and drive to Nauyer Road. We are currently acquiring right of way and getting very close
to completing that right of way acquisition so when we bring you contracts like this it means
we're getting really close to construction. And what happened? Oh yeah go ahead. Madam President if I can
interrupt why are we looking at a microwave? Yeah and I'm sorry because it's been a long night
there's so many stuff up here when I closed my PowerPoint. Great point because I kind of looked
at it and I can't read it from here so I didn't really know what it was but but irrelevant to this
so so under federal guidelines depending on a utility's annual grocery seats you qualify for
100 percent reimbursement of relocation. So for Huntsville Utilities water system and gas system
it's very the same for Madison County water so on here we have actually two one is Huntsville
Utilities gas other one's Madison County water which services that area and what it does it helps
you know federal aid project road project telling a local utility you need to move out of the way
and they say look all you're going to do is cause our rates to go up you know so federal policy says
the federal aid project will relocate that cost so both M and N is is doing that so you have to
approve it there are no costs to the city this is 100 federal funds so there's no cost to our capital
plan. Questions for Mr. Davis all in favor indicate aye. Motion carries 20 and is resolution
authorizing mayor to enter into reimbursable agreement between the city of Huntsville and
Huntsville Utilities for relocation of utility facilities on private or public right of way
for Winchester Road gas relocation project project number 71-26-SP18 and project number ACAA 61222
to a trip is there a motion motion for Mr. Little second second for Mr. Meredith Mr. Davis
same just more of the same utility yes ma'am any questions miss Watkins oh no just want you to
explain it so people would know what it was thank you I'm glad we're letting the public know this
project got stalled out really bad during COVID and then we had to get project this this project
needs to get to construction and we're going as quickly as possible to get there any questions
all in favor please indicate aye. Council members I know urban development and administration brought
you a lot of stuff tonight thank you for your support and patience as as we brought a lot before
you tonight thank you for your very good work 20Q is a resolution authorizing the mayor to execute
a memorandum of understanding between the city of Huntsville and NCI Meridian LLC and their sole
member and manager neighborhood concepts inc is there a motion motion to approve motion for Mr.
Meredith second from Mr. Little we have any questions regarding this
any questions okay then all in favor please indicate aye. Opposed motion carries 20R is a
resolution off-tribal mayor to enter a new standard agreement for architectural services between the
city of Huntsville and Nolivan-Person Architects PC for the Dr. Richard Showers Center renovation
is there a motion second motion from Ms. Watkins second from Mr. Meredith good evening Ricky
Wilkinson director of general services so this is an architectural services contract for the design
of the Richard Showers Center renovation the amount of this contract is one million three hundred
thirty four thousand and five hundred dollars this process started about a year and a half ago we hired
NVP Nolivan-Person to do an assessment on the facility the Dr. Richard Showers Center we have
since then had several public meetings a town hall meeting with the residents obvious various users
of the facility and other stakeholders during this process we did consider renovation as well as
demolition of the facility and the general consensus of our team as well as the you know the
attendees of the latest town hall meeting last month was to move forward with the renovation
project so with your approval tonight this will allow us to put pencil to paper and start the
design process right now the proposed concept includes site improvements to include an outdoor
basketball court new pickleball courts an expanded parking lot improved parking lot drainage up there
an upgraded playground and an improved walking path around the campus inside the building we're
looking at new finishes rearranging the building entrance to add a new lobby area more attractive
lobby area replacement of building systems to include hvac units we are adding air conditioning
to the gym i know that's very important as well and upgrades to the pool and pool equipment systems
happy to answer any questions you may have questions or comments from Mr. Wilkinson Ms.
Watkins thank you Mr. Wilkinson could you tell me you know if council approves this tonight
how long would it take Nolivan-Person to come back with some renderings for us yeah so we will start
you know obviously we have kind of a master plan rendering that we showed at the town hall but we're
going to work through our standard design process my hope is that my expectation is that within a
year from now we're actually bringing a construction contract before council so i expect you know
certainly within the next eight to ten months we've got finalized drawings so it'll be eight to ten
months to get the finalized drawings then it'll come back before council and then probably two or
three months after that we should have a construction contract in place right that's my expectation is
within a year from now i'll just say a year from now we're bringing a construction contract
what we would have gone through the bidding process and we're ready to begin work and the
reason why i'm asking just for the listening public so they understand that we are going to do this
but we got to get the drawings first and i want to thank you because you came to the shower center
to a public meeting you're very patient and gracious with answering the questions and i
just appreciate you so much and thank you for staying late tonight thank you that's my job
mr merrick um yes uh it's been a while since i've been there but if i'm not mistaken there is a
freestanding why or or some some freestanding building where is used for daycare is that going
to be affected or is that going to continue to to allow to be there so um we have had some
consideration right now there's no direct plan to renovate the ymca daycare that is a city-owned
facility they do lease it from the city we do as part of the playground renovation it does and
parking lot expansion it does affect certain areas and again this is all based on the conceptual
design but certainly as we work through the formal design process i do anticipate some impacts and
we have communicated that to the ymca staff up there as well as some of the other user groups
but to define that right now would be a little bit difficult to do just because we're not 100
on the design but we will certainly communicate with the ymca and other user groups any kind of
impact as we get those established i would just i know this is miss watkins district but i would
really love for them to be for the impact negative impact to them to be as minimal as possible we
have to have quality places where working adults can know that their children are well looked after
and they're in safe environment and we just we got to keep that availability there for people sure
all those in favor say aye aye motion carries thank you thank you very much mr wilkinson 20t
is resolution just salary of an employee in a certain position in a signed department
is there a motion to approve second motion from mr little second with mr meredith any
particular questions on this so um i know i've asked this question several times but
i have to ask again because when you see um these items on the agenda and people are getting step
increases or they're getting um a grade increase sometime employees call you because they want to
know why are they getting it and i'm not getting it and so i know i've asked before and um i remember
you know we're talking about it being a difficult task but is it at all possible can we at least
look at for the budget that's coming up can we look at doing an evaluation of positions a job audit
to make sure everyone is at their grade level and at their step level because it seems like it's
reoccurring and i'm definitely not trying to be difficult but if you're an employee on the outside
looking in and you keep seeing people get step increases or grade increases and it's always i
know you said that sometimes people can request an audit but these individuals sometime when they call
you know they're too afraid to ask for a job audit because they don't want it to be seem like they're
um they're uh complaining but at the same time it would i just would love for us to try to get an
audit other positions to make sure everyone is at their grade level and at their step level
and that way we don't have to keep getting them to come back over and over again with this
when i was at Huntsville city schools and i'm not trying to compare us but we did a job audit
because we had the same issue with employees you know some were getting increased some weren't and
they didn't understand it but if we had a job audit to audit these positions position audit
then that would tell us exactly where the individuals are supposed to be just something
for consideration i'm not asking you to say yes just something for consideration anyway and i'll
talk to HR director i one thing i would like to say to that because you know obviously to y'all
but but also i know we have employees watching and so in a way a message to our employees that are
that are engaged in this process you know by policy by ordinance all of our employees have a
right to request an audit of their position and and no employee should feel embarrassed or
intimidated to not take advantage of that right that is their right and they absolutely can do it
one of the things you know so you know and this is different than an audit uh there's a you know a
couple different ways where you'll see great or step kind of decisions related to employees and so
what you see basically quarterly is the result of that quarter's audits that employees or department
heads i've had times where an employee has not asked for an audit but a department has come in
and said i don't believe we're you know appropriately grading and compensating this
employee and the department head can initiate an audit and that happens sometimes one of the
things that i don't when when mr by when mr thomas brings you that change it's either where a
position maybe it was the right grade but needed a different title or it might have been a grade
change you're seeing the ones where they found the need to change i don't believe you're seeing the
ones where the audit came back that they're exactly correctly titled and graded and every
quarter there's a number of those that are happening and so there's a lot of positions
getting audited that just don't come to you because you have no decision to make if there's
no changes right so so that is one piece of it what is happening tonight is kind of another
example where department heads and evaluating where their employees are and where they are in
their compensation this is an example where the positions are properly graded but because of kind
of the dynamics of where the automatic step increase process works for employees it has them
in their individual circumstances out of alignment within you know the department has judgment you
know they come to me i assess it along with hr director agree with that that's why we bring it
to you as a recommendation so this is probably the more common example of this type of transaction
you see you know every so often when one pops up where uh you know they within our system when an
employee gets promoted they get a five percent raise per grade so if you if you go two grades up
you know from a from a more junior position up to like i say a managerial position you go two grades
that would be a 10 10 percent raise to whatever step gives you at least 10 so sometimes it might
be 10.5 or 11 just based on where it falls within our step structure but in some cases we have
employees that based on where they where they were and they get raised up into a supervisory
position that's the example here and that that automatic system that y'all have authorized by
ordinance did not get them where they ought to be relative to the people they supervise
and so you've got situations where an employee is now managing and supervising others and make
substantially less than their subordinates and so what we've tried to do is be consistent in making
sure that we've acknowledged that increased responsibility but by ordinance a a kind of
out of sequence step increase we have to bring to you for your decision and so you've seen these
occasionally it's on a case-by-case basis and so that's an example that's happening here tonight
i understand that's not exactly what you're asking i totally understand your point and let me i'll
spend some time with with Byron Thomas and kind of talk through you know what maybe some of the
options are there but i think it's important to note and i appreciate you you pointing out that
sometimes employees may feel embarrassed or whatever to go and and essentially ask for a raise
but what they're doing is not just for them personally they are when when they when a position
has changed a new scope of duties has come into a position you know they're helping us identify the
fact that we need to restructure that position to to be competitive in the market but also to
to make sure that we're fair across all our employees and so i don't i don't want any employee
to feel embarrassed or intimidated to not ask for that audit that's absolutely their right yeah
and i appreciate you taking time to answer those questions thank you thank you mr hamilton any
other questions all in favor please indicate aye opposed motion carries we're making progress
20 next we'll go to a a 20 a a 20 a as a resolution authorizing the city attorney to submit certain
questions to the office of the attorney general of alabama relative to certain elected municipal
officials and the alabama municipal official training act code of alabama section 11-40-100
at sick and requesting issuance of an attorney general's opinion relative there to motion for
mr little second for mr cling is are there questions or comments regarding this any questions
any questions comments all in favor please indicate excuse me oh i'm sorry before we go further
can mr riley at least explain what this is so the public will know sure sure there was recently a
new law passed uh that required may basically mayors and council persons to obtain annual uh
uh training and such it's 10 10 year 10 hours a year 40 hours total and it has an effective date
of january 1 2025 however the statute was unclear whether mayors and council persons
uh whose terms were started before that effective date whether it applied to them or that only
applied to people whose terms of office first term of office begins after that effective day
so the council has asked me to submit a request as we can do to the attorney general's office for
their opinion and part of that process is that the governing body has to authorize me to do so
and that's what this is tonight thank you any other comments all in favor please indicate i
i suppose motion carries 20 ab is a resolution authorized mayor to enter into agreement between
the city of huntsville and the arts council is there a motion motion for mr little second from
the chair um anybody have any questions about this yes if you could just briefly explain what
this is yes council member this is uh the annual agreement that we do about this time every year
uh that is the user agreement for big spring park west uh that is really kind of between parks and
recreation and the arts council uh now doing business as arts huntsville for the uh concerts
in the park series so uh starting at the beginning of june through i think it's september or so every
monday night there's a free concert out there and so this is their user agreement for that part of
the park thank you any other questions all in favor please indicate i motion carries
ac is a resolution authorized mayor to enter new facility use agreement between the city of huntsville
and rocket city culture foundation for the event rocket city culture fest is there a motion
motion from mr lill second from the chair second second from mr cling motion by mr lil second by
mr cling any questions about anybody have about this yes mr hamilton if you could just briefly
explain make sure this is so this is a private organizer who's putting on what we think is going
to be a great music and cultural event in big butler green so it's uh you know standard user
agreement for the park but uh because they will also have alcohol service there they have to get
a special event alcohol license from the state the state requires them to actually have a lease
agreement or a facility use agreement approved by the governing body in order to apply for that
alcohol license so we have reviewed their plan they do have a good plan for security and things
it's an appropriate use of the park but it it has to come to you because of that component related
to alcohol sales anybody have questions all in favor please indicate i pose motion carries
20 ad is resolution off-tribe mayor to enter new summer food service program permanent agreement
for unaffiliated sites between the city of huntsville and huntsville city schools for services
at the dr richards hours center uh cavalry hills recreation center and brun spring recreation
center is there a motion motion for mr clain second for mr little council members what's before
you is you're seeing this for the first time though it's a program that's been going for a
number of years uh the school system has federal funding that they use to assist with a summer
feeding program for uh for youth 18 and under uh they've done it for a number of years and it
occurs at a number of locations around the city where i'm focused on the ones that are actually
city facilities and they're listed there at those particular recreation centers in the past they
have not needed to have a formal agreement like this apparently some rules changed on the federal
program where they get their funding from that actually requires them to have a governing body
approved lease agreement for those facilities there are our staff and you say your parks and rec staff
is involved in fact the the facility managers have some very specific duties to assist in the
management of the program and so the school system provides them the training they need and the
oversight they need to to facilitate the program but this is new to you though it's an old program
just because of the new requirements for an approval for the for the leasing the facilities
any questions or comments i want to thank the city for partnering with hoslin city schools to
provide this summer feed program so i'll some opportunity especially when the kids are there
at the facilities uh whether they're in camp or they're there plan then this get them opportunity
to be fed so thank you for that any other comments mr murray yes um i'd like to know why
after my explicitly asking that there be a summer feeding service program location in district five
that there still is not a location in district five why can't the west huntsville rec center
be a site for the folks in district five to enjoy this uh opportunity as well my belief is uh and
and that there there could be but we need that the school system runs the program so i'll need to
engage with the school system to find out what what other sites they have uh and where if there's
gaps in that then we would certainly i'd be happy to make the west huntsville rec center available
for for that purpose if it if it fits within their program but ultimately uh we need to engage with
them to uh to find out exactly how they position these around the community so if you could do
that i know i've talked with uh school board president carlos mathews about this and he
would certainly uh like west huntsville rec center to participate in this but i'm sure there's other
things that he has to and the school board needs to go through but if you could check on that and
uh hopefully facilitate that happening i'd be great sure thank you any other comments or questions
all in favor please indicate aye motion carries that unless i have missed something i believe that
concludes we took that out we took that out of order yeah we took af out of order so that brings
us to new items new business items for introduction we only have one 21a is introduction of an ordinance
concerning a rights of way use agreement between spectrum southeast llc delaware limited liability
company and the city of huntsville alabama no action will be taken on that tonight it will be
considered in the may 28th meeting and then finally on our agenda we have the second roster
public comments and we do have a couple of people signed up this portion of the meeting is reserved
for persons wishing to address council matters relating to the city business whether or not such
items are on the meeting agenda you may sign up to speak on the these persons have signed up to
speak on the second public comments roster prior to meeting when called approach the microphone
state your name home address city residents each speaker may address the council for three minutes
speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue with council members or city staff and
from making comments regarding good name and character of any individual the first person to
sign up is howard ross is mr ross here and mr ross will be followed by joe winston
i'm here again on the issue of apparently trespassing at 6016
ellington road that the police were at and just trying to find out it's been several meetings and
i was told that the police were going to get back with me was a police the assistant to the to the
chief michael johnson and i haven't heard back from him and i haven't also the city administrator
city administrator haven't heard back from him and just there's been no investigator apparently
appointed and it's been over two months and we're trying to find out who's gonna who's going to
handle this that seems to be dead in the water and i didn't know if there was again i thought there was
a city council person from that district who might be able to assist in finding out how we can get
this issue resolved and i believe mr hamilton could you have a conversation or yes i believe
what i spoke with you the last meeting did we not yes and you said it was a difficult issue and we
don't know what that means well i understand that and i i'm not the person that will resolve that
issue if you're indicating there's an investigation or that you're waiting on a result i'll be happy
to check on that yeah i don't know that we want to do about uh back and forth here so um perhaps
the best thing to do would be for you to have a conversation with mr hamilton if there's an
investigator i'd like to know thank you we'll now go on and hear from mr joe winston mr winston
will be followed by kaden helbling
good evening uh the name is joe winston uh addresses 180 105 great mark drive uh madison
alabama uh the subject i wanted to readdress again that's been addressed several times as a black art
black history museum here in the city of uh hansville and i have to back up a little bit
because i'm going back to last year when i uh contacted the mayor regarding having a black art
black history museum here in the city of hansville going back to june or 2025 uh after contacting the
mayor he responded uh thank you for your letter of may 27th and he uh stated that several years ago
we worked to establish a black history uh trail and a museum of some sort in hansville but uh the
representation at that time became kind of light and uh he said during those meetings he was pointed
out that alabama enm had the state of uh alabama black black archives and so he said quickly the uh
the the attention the enthusiasm kind of feels allowed and therefore did not go any further and he
said maybe we had the wrong audience at that point in time that we were talking with now i've been a
resident of hansville for over 25 years i didn't recall that not to say that didn't happen but i
didn't recall the time when that went out to the community and he also said that he would refer
that to uh dr barbara uh to uh to look into it and also started some meetings and dr barbara asked me
for some some comments regarding places and organizations to contact an idea that i matter
fact sent him about over 20 some different locations uh and uh agencies to contact uh that
never happened i know he's a busy fellow but that never happened last year and i will also uh
remind us that uh last year in september i made another presentation trying to get something put
on the budget in terms of uh establishing the black art black history museum uh that uh i was
told was a little late for doing that so again i bring it to the council's attention to uh look
at the budgets in that we are in the month of may and we are in the month of june and we are in the
uh look at the budgets in that we are in the month of may and which gives us a little time to uh look
at the budgets in terms of establishing some funding to establish a black art black history museum
and i would also remind us that black americans have profoundly shaped u.s history through
cultural political scientific and social achievement despite the centuries of oppression
and systematic uh slavery both in civil rights cultural and artistic uh achievement scientific
and educational achievements military science political achievements and the list goes on
uh also i would like to remind us that just recently april 1 2026 we witnessed the uh
sorry mr winston your time is up okay thank you very much hearing from you again next meeting
uh we now will hear from kaden helbling who will be followed by lilliana painter
yeah good evening i'm kaden helbling my address is on the sheet i am in huntsville thank you um
i'm here tonight to speak regarding a breakdown in administrative transparency
and the city's failure to adhere to the alabama open records act concerning the flock safety
surveillance system for several months i've attempted to access basic administrative uh
audit logs for this taxpayer funded system through several public records requests um these requests
do not seek to uh do not seek investigative files video footage or sensitive evidence i am simply
asking for the organizational audit or network audit reports that flock safety's own contracts
defined as accountability and oversight tools the city's legal department has denied these
requests by citing the mac decision claiming these automated system logs are investigative materials
this is this is a significant overreach there is a fundamental difference between a video recording
of a crime and an administrative computer log showing which agencies are sharing data
and whether authorized personnel are following policy the entire point of an independent public
audit is to ensure individual accountability without these unmasked logs there is no way for
the public or this council to know if individual offers officers are abusing this massive
surveillance system for personal reasons such as monitoring neighbors or stalking ex-partners
rather than solving crimes furthermore after filing a formal legal appeal on march 4th
i've been met with over 60 days of silence from mr riley here and assistant attorney eddie blair
emails and status inquiries to the office have gone completely unanswered transparency is not
an optional feature of government it is a legal requirement when the city spends public funds on
automated surveillance the public has a right to see the audit trails that ensure the technology
is being used legally and ethically i'm asking the council to look into why mr riley and mr blair
have stopped responding to these inquiries and direct them to provide these administrative logs
so that this community can verify that this technology is being used appropriately all right
if anyone in the audience is concerned about this lack of oversight i have information on how you
can map these cameras and file your own requests thank you for your time thank you sir we will now
hear from our last speaker david oh i'm sorry next we'll hear from lilliana painter is miss painter
here i saw her earlier in the meeting i don't see her now so we will hear from david snider
oh there she is
yes miss painter
good evening council my name is lilliana painter and my address is correct on the sheet i'm a
huntsville resident thank you thank you oh i want to begin by acknowledging that i appreciate seeing
the investment in flood and flood maps water infrastructure environmental planning and growth
management those investments uh recognize an important reality huntsville is no longer
experiencing moderate growth we are now the largest city in alabama we are continuing to grow
into a significantly larger and more complex regional center we see it through roadway expansion
utility scaling annexation development districts energy infrastructure and even precinct restructuring
ahead of the upcoming municipal election and as huntsville grows into a fundamentally larger city
our infrastructure public investment and systems of representation must evolve with it because
residents are already feeling the strain of growth in their daily lives they feel it sitting in
traffic longer than they did just a few years ago they feel it on crowded roads and infrastructure
struggling to keep pace they feel it through rising costs pressure on schools concerns around
public safety and frustration when decisions feel like they are happening around them instead of with
them residents do not experience growth through development announcements or economic reports
they experience whether their daily lives are becoming easier or harder for people
that already live here whether neighborhoods still feel safe and connected whether they feel
represented whether they feel heard that is why this moment requires more than growth
planning alone it requires earlier public education stronger resident engagement and thoughtful
conversations about representation as our city continues expanding because when precincts are
being added and voting boundaries are being restructured it is fair to ask whether our
system of representation should evolve alongside the the size and complexity of our city
a larger huntsville requires larger thinking and if we want huntsville to remain competitive long
term we must continue investing not only in attracting talent from across the country and
internationally but also in ensuring that residents that already live here have the opportunity to
to thrive alongside the growth that starts with strong public education transparent governance
coordinated infrastructure planning and preserving the quality of life thank you thank you miss
painter for your comments of course and now we will hear from david snider
hello my name is david snider i live in huntsville my information is written across the country
my information is written correctly on the sheet and i want to first open up by talking about
my recent public speaking at the public comments roster for the county right so i went in front
of the county about several programs i'm trying to work with and establish at the jail which is
the mcso and that's the county right i believe that our city should support people that are in
uh or the honorable judge civil cleveland's unsheltered docket right we should be supporting
these people with bus passes possibly a shuttle for when people are leaving the jail in this program
also through my coursework with the civic engagement academy i spoke with our music
director our department of music director matt mandrella and i think that if we were to establish
a music program to bring into the juvenile facility which is also a county-run facility
that would be an excellent thing these are things that you know would really serve our communities
well right so i would really appreciate help on that i'm meeting soon with cleveland our judge
to talk about that i've also had communications with bill cling my district member and kisha bryant
the public transit director about accomplishing this and so i would really appreciate support from
the council on these issues i do want to talk a little bit also about you know some sentiment that
i've come to city council meetings many many times i've met with several our officials several times
and i there is a sentiment that i've heard come out of council about you know non-partisanship
or about accepting some of the status quo that has happened federally and i think that we need
to take a hard look at what that is i just want to remind the council that throughout history in
this country there have been as early as you know john b nox and the founding of the 1901 state
constitution right i'm said explicitly that in as much as the federal constitution will allow we
would like to establish white supremacy in the state of alabama right this has happened where
people have come and explained that they used their agency to write you know draconian drug laws and
sentencing so the concept that having agency with your position of power is known people are using
it and you know the a sentiment that we have to accept federally what's happening or what's
happening at the state level regarding immigration regarding you know how we are treating our
community members is unacceptable also i heard earlier i believe that we are going to come into
acquisition we're acquiring the federal courthouse the they're they're moving i think that a black
history museum as i've said several times and we deserve as a people a black history museum and that
would be potentially an excellent location for that and so i think that should really be considered
thank you sir that concludes our citizen comments from the evening and the business of the city is
there a motion to adjourn please note the time is 9 33